gwendolyn faraday previously created one
of the most popular view courses on the
internet now she's back with an all new
full view course to teach the latest
version to absolute beginners
hi everyone my name is gwendolyn faraday
and i will be your instructor for this
course
i have been a professional software
developer for over five years now and i
have had the opportunity to work in
several different languages and
frameworks over the years including
angular react and vue.js i currently
work as a software consultant in various
technologies
and use vue.js as my preferred front-end
framework for any type of web or mobile
application
if you would like to reach out to me you
can find me anywhere online at faraday
academy
if you have any specific feedback for
this course
please email me at gwenf at
protonmail.com i hope you enjoyed this
course
vue.js is a javascript framework for
building applications and websites
how does it help you
it provides tools out of the box to help
you make your websites and apps faster
and more dynamic
and it also gives you a set of standards
for code organization and expectations
for individuals and teams that work in
the same code base
if you have heard of the virtual dom
before vue.js is a virtual dom framework
if you don't know what that is it's okay
it's not important for understanding
this course
the virtual dom basically makes
javascript web applications a little bit
faster and more efficient
vue by itself is extremely lightweight
you can get it down to about eight or
ten kilobytes gzipped
although in a practical sense your view
and bundled javascript will probably
never be that small in an application
anyway although it is good to know that
vue doesn't have a lot of extra code
taking up more space in your application
why does vue.js call itself a
progressive framework
they use the term progressive to mean
that you can use it anywhere from
small features on websites where you
want to add some interactivity and using
it
as kind of a drop-in replacement for
jquery and legacy applications
all the way up to using it as a more
full-featured batteries included
framework for large-scale applications
like a gmail or twitter or something
like that
you get to decide what features you want
to add in from the view ecosystem beyond
the core library
and it's extremely flexible to allow you
to choose the tools and other libraries
you want on your own
or you can use the ones that vue
provides in its ecosystem by default
many people and companies are using it
for its incrementally adoptable nature
that means that if they have a legacy
application it's quite simple to update
their application page by page to turn
it into a view application into a more
modern application
instead of having to rewrite the whole
app at once
that is one very convenient thing about
vue.js
let's look at a really quick overview of
the history of vue
the view project was started in 2013 by
its founder evan yu in 2014 version 1
launched
and it started to become popular in
china where avenue is from
a few years later view 2 was launched
with many new updates and improvements
over view version one
and with the release of version two is
really where we start to see the massive
growth of vue.js in popularity in the
rest of the world
so many developers had not heard of ujs
before 2017
but from 2017 and especially in 2018 and
2019 vue really solidified itself as one
of the top three javascript frameworks
many view conferences started popping up
lots of content creation around the view
ecosystem started to take place and many
companies started to use vue for their
applications as well
in fact many companies that you
recognize which are household names in
the west use vue.js now
and now we can see that view version 3
has been released in fall of 2020
and along the way over these last six
years we see many different libraries
that are also created and maintained by
avenue and the core team of view like
the vcli view router and view x
also being regularly updated to match
with the current version of view
even now with view 3 just released we
see that a new version of view router
and vx have also been released to be
compatible with vue version 3.
in this course we will be using the
vue.js core library as well as the vcli
for more information on vue x v router
view test details and some of the other
tools in the vue ecosystem that i don't
cover in depth in this course i will be
making future courses about those on my
faraday academy youtube channel
so let's get started with learning
vue.js
and keep in mind i'm using v3 here so
make sure you are at the correct website
which is v3.viewjs.org
and then click on getting started here
this will take you to the documentation
and by default the introduction to vjs
i'm going to go straight to the
installation link on the sidebar here
and if i scroll down i can see the place
where it says cdn
and you'll notice here it says view at
next make sure you are importing the
right library from the right url here at
next is necessary because view 3 is not
in the main viewjs
repository yet it's in this other
repository that you can reference with
at next
which points to view three
until the whole ecosystem and everything
finishes getting updated there is going
to be a difference between importing
view two
and importing view at next which points
to view version three
and i'm going to go ahead and grab this
script tag here
so i'm in vs code and i just have a
basic html file
and i'll be adding vue.js into this
application to demonstrate the basics of
view syntax before i get into building a
larger application with the vue cli
so first of all i'm going to be using a
vs code plugin
called live server you can see at the
bottom here it says go live
so if you go to plugins which is this
four box icon on the side
you can type in live server
and click on this plugin
and you can install it if you do not
already have it installed but i already
have it installed and enabled so i'm
gonna go back to my code over here and
at the bottom i'll just click go live
and you can see it shows my html page
i'll just zoom in a little bit here with
the static content
now if you don't want to use live server
you can just come here and right click
and
click on copy path
and then you can go to your browser and
paste that absolute path to the project
or to your index.html file
and it will display the same way in the
browser live server just makes things a
bit easier because it will automatically
refresh when you make code changes and
it also opens up the browser page for
you but it's up to you if you want to
use it or not
so now i want to add view to this
application
so i'm going to go inside of the body
tag and just below this div
just paste in the script tag that i just
copied so now this is all that i have to
do to import view and start using it in
my application i don't actually need
babble or anything else to get started
so to write my own custom code i'm going
to add my own script tag right below
that
so there's basically two things that i
need to do here and the first
is to
use this view variable that i have
access to from importing view in that
script tag and vue gives me this method
called create app
and that basically creates my view
application and i can pass it an options
object which i'll get to in a second
now i need to somehow connect this
javascript for my view application
with the html
that i'm going to be displaying in the
browser
and that is through another method that
i can actually chain on to this view
instance i'm creating
so i'm actually going to save this as a
variable i'm going to say let app equals
view dot create app
and then
i'm going to use this other method
called mount because i want to tell it
to mount my view application somewhere
in my html here
so i'll do id equals
i'll just call it app
and i'm actually going to tell it to
mount my ujs application inside of that
div
and that means that the vue.js instance
that i'm creating here will be able to
connect and display data and interact
with any kind of dom element inside of
this div here so that will be more clear
in a second
so now let me change this let me
create a variable on my view instance
and to do this i need to create a
function called data here now this whole
object here is called the options object
so any variables or functions that i'm
going to use in my application will live
on this object here
so specifically with data that is a
function
and it needs to return an object
and on this object that is returned by
the data function i can put whatever
variables i want
so i'm gonna create a greeting variable
and
i'm basically going to say hello view
three
then exclamation point
and now i can actually go into my div
here
delete that static code there
and i'm going to use my variable now so
to use a variable in view
you use this double curly brace syntax
it's called double mustache syntax which
is kind of hard to pronounce so you can
just call it double curly braces it's a
common syntax in templating languages
and it basically means that anything
found in between these sets of double
curly braces will be parsed as
javascript by view
so view is first going to look inside of
this data object that we're returning
and see if there is a variable named
greeting
and then it is going to display that
variable or the value of that variable
inside of these curly braces
and you can see that now it displays
the greeting variable from our view
instance
let's talk about vue.js directives
they are basically a way to connect
elements in our html or template here
with the vue.js javascript and let's see
what that looks like through an example
i'm going to create an input here
in the browser it looks like this
now what if i want to get the value out
of this input
view has a built-in way to do that
through a directive called v model now
these directives in view are used just
like an html attribute but they are
prepended with v dash to differentiate
them from regular html attributes and
view when it is parsing this view
application we'll see this keyword v
model and we'll bind it to whatever
variable we pass in as an argument to
the model here so here inside quotes i
need to put a variable name
and i'm actually going to put the
variable greeting here
and let's see what that does
so you can see now in my input it
actually starts off with the text hello
view
and as i change it
it also changes the greeting variable
that is displayed on the page
this is called two-way data binding and
is handled in view with that v model
directive
let's look at another directive
i'm going to create an hr here
and i'll make a div
with a class of box
and i'm going to use another directive
here called v if
which also takes an argument which will
be another variable
so i'm going to set an is visible
variable which i have to create so let
me do is visible
and set this to
true to start
i am going to paste in some styling
that i made this is just to style the
box so you can see it on the page i'll
fold that
you can see that i do see that box
because this v if directive
is basically just like
an if statement in javascript so if this
value is truthy then this element will
be displayed on the page
but if it's false this div will not be
rendered to the dom at all so let me
change this variable to false
and you can see the box disappears
and if i check i can inspect element
and there is no div found in the dom
now v if is very similar to v show
which is another vue.js directive
it takes the same kind of argument a
boolean expression and let me set this
to true again
you can see if it's true it shows on the
page just like v if
however when it's false you can see
there's still a div
rendered to the dom
the only difference is the style is set
to display none
so you won't actually see it but it is
there in the dom
so when would you use v show
well in most cases you would just use v
if
because you either want something to
render or not
like if you have a loading spinner you
would use v if it's loading show the
spinner
and then when the page or whatever has
loaded you would set the variable to
false and then v if would remove it from
the dom
now v show
is useful for specific cases
when you might need to toggle something
more frequently
and it would be more performant than
adding and removing it to the dom
constantly so it's already there all
you're doing is changing the css
so you're changing it from display none
to display block
so changing this back to v if
there are other directives that you can
chain onto v if there's v elsif and v
else
and you can already guess what these do
so
i'm just going to show you the syntax
here so v else if
and
v else is the one that doesn't take any
argument
and i'm just going to demonstrate these
really quickly
i'll add another variable here so is
visible is visible too
so i've added a little bit more css here
to differentiate between the three boxes
that i've created here
and this works as a regular if else
statement so if is visible is true this
div will be rendered
if it's not true it's going to keep
going down the chain so it'll look at
any of the else ifs you have here you
can have as many as you want so then it
will look at is visible 2 to see if that
is true if that's not true then it will
automatically display this third box
now the third box is blue
the second box is red and the first box
is purple
so you can see the blue box displayed
because the other two values were false
likewise i could change one of these
variables to true
and then that box would be rendered in
the dom here
now i want to point something out here
if i refresh the page you can see for a
split second you actually saw all of the
boxes render as well as the curly braces
show up on the screen here before it was
parsed as a view variable
i'm going to refresh the page again and
slow it down a little bit just in case
you couldn't see that
so how do i prevent that from happening
vue has something called v cloak which
is a convenient utility that will hide
anything from rendering until
the whole view application is ready
so i'm going to add a v cloak here
and then i basically need to add a style
for it
so you can see
i'm setting v cloak or this v cloak
attribute to display none this is the
recommended pattern in vjs
and then i just add a v cloak to my div
with my app in it
now if i go back here and refresh you no
longer see the curly braces or the other
boxes render how does that happen
i'm going to go to inspect element
and you can see on the div with id app
here there is no vcloak attribute but if
i refresh the page you can't really see
it because it's too fast but basically
that v cloak attribute remains on this
div until the app is loaded and then
it's removed once everything is rendered
to the dom
i don't often run into cases where i
have to manually use this but it is a
nice feature to know about if you run
into that issue
these were just a few basic directives
we will definitely be covering more
directives as we go along in this course
in the next video we will go over events
and methods in vjs
now that you've seen how to use
variables and directives in vjs
let's make this code a little bit more
interactive with events
so you probably already know that there
are many events that can be captured in
the browser and used in our applications
for example when the user clicks on an
element on the screen like a button
or if the user presses a certain key on
the keyboard like enter to submit a form
let's try out both of these cases in our
little mini application here
first
i'm going to get rid of the two extra
boxes
and i'm going to add a button here
which for right now i will label as show
box
so right now this v if is set to false
or the variable is visible set to false
so this div will never be rendered on
the page unless we somehow update that
variable
before we were hard coding the variable
value here as true or false but we can
actually use this button to change the
variable value as well
and this is done with another directive
called v dash on
now the v dash on directive is specific
for events
you can use it for custom events that
you create yourself
or you can use it for any of the
standard browser events like as i
mentioned before when a user clicks or
presses a key on their keyboard
so here specifically i'm going to do v
on colon and then the type of event
which will be a click event
so i'm listening for a click event
on this button right now
but now when someone clicks on the
button i have to tell view what to do
with that click event
so i need to pass in an argument of
whatever javascript i want to run when
this button is clicked and for right now
i will keep it simple and i'm going to
set the is visible variable
to true
when that button is clicked
now you can see i have this button show
box
when it's clicked the box shows what if
i want to hide the box right now this
only shows the box
and the only way to get rid of it is by
refreshing
i can set up a toggle for the box
by simply saying is visible equals the
opposite of whatever it currently is
so is visible equals not is visible
so if it's true it will be set to false
if it's false it will be set to true and
this should toggle our box
i'll re-label this to toggle box
and now
if i keep clicking it toggles on and off
that is basically how events work there
is also a shorthand for creating events
so you don't have to type out v dash on
colon
you can just type
the at symbol and then the event name
and this is exactly the same thing as it
was when i typed v dash on colon the at
symbol just replaces all of that
so what if you wanted to do something
more complex in here not just setting a
variable to true or false
well you can actually use this to pass
in any kind of method on your vjs object
so i'm going to get rid of is visible
here
and i'm going to
create a method called togglebox
and now i have to create this togglebox
method
you can see i already have data
on my vjs object this data function
but now i need to make another key which
is called methods
and methods is an object of functions
i can put as many functions as i want on
this methods object to be able to use
these in my vjs application
so
let me create that
togglebox function i could do the same
thing here
as i did above but i'm just going to use
the function shorthand
and i want the same logic again but
inside this function
so in order to refer to this is visible
variable here i have to get it off of
the this context
and vue.js handles putting all of my
methods and variables on the this
context so that they're available to me
anywhere in my view application
so i can do this dot is
visible and then set it equal to not
this dot is visible
this is not a function there
and this should work the same way as it
did before
so i can test it out and toggle the box
once again
so that is the basics of how methods
work
and you can see because i have called my
method togglebox that it is also
available to me
anywhere inside my vgas template here
so let's look at one more type of event
and that will be an event listening for
keyboard input
so here i want to listen for key presses
this is also an event so i'm going to
start with the at symbol and listen for
a key up event i could also use key down
if i wanted to
so for keyboard events i need to add a
modifier to say which keyboard input i
am listening for
so for input here i want to run a
function or some javascript whenever i
press the enter key so for enter i
actually have a shorthand because this
is a common keyboard input so i can say
listen for the key up event specifically
with the enter key or i can always use
the key code associated with any key on
the keyboard so for enter that would be
13.
it doesn't matter which one i use
i'm just going to go ahead and use key
up dot enter because it's a bit more
obvious what it is
and then it's the same syntax here
and i'm going to create a greet method
for this key up event
so let me go down to my methods
create a method called greet
use the method shorthand
and i'm actually just going to
console.log
this dot greeting
and let's see how that works
so i can just focus this input anywhere
and just hit enter it doesn't matter
what's already in the input
and you can see it logs out the greeting
if i change the input it logs out
whatever the greeting variable is
currently set to
now what if i want to pass something
into a function as i'm calling it
into one of these methods
then i could do that
just by adding the parentheses to call
the function
so for example greet here i can just
pass something in
so just for demonstration purposes i'm
going to pass in the greeting
through the template here
i'm going to accept that here and i'll
still call it greeting
and then
get rid of this because i'm no longer
looking for the greeting variable
on the vjs instance here
i am actually
just going to be using the greeting
variable that i am passing in here
and just to show you that it's different
i can use the greeting variable and then
pass it in with some exclamation points
appended to it
and now when i go here and i click enter
again
you can see that it is the greeting
variable that i passed in through the
template
if i
erase a few characters here hit enter
again you can see it's still the same
variable set to the new value
those are the basics of how to use
events and methods in vjs
i do want to point out here you see this
dot enter that is an event modifier in
vue.js
so you're not only listening to the key
up event you're listening to
specifically the enter key now there are
many modifiers that you can use for
example
at this click event here
for example i could add a modifier here
that says i'm only listening for right
clicks so a normal left click on a mouse
will not trigger this toggle box but
only if you make a right click i can
also use some handy modifiers
like prevent
so if i don't want a form to submit
instead of using the regular event dot
prevent default in my method
i can just add this modifier here dot
prevent and i can do that for stop
propagation as well so i could add dot
stop you can chain as many of these
modifiers as you want in vjs they're
definitely a handy thing to know about
when you're building view applications
that's all for this video we will be
diving deeper into events and methods
later on in this course and in future
courses
in the next video we're going to talk
about custom components in vjs
let's talk about view components
now when we created our view application
here
we are basically just using one standard
component you could call it
just a default options object for use in
our template so now we're going to work
on breaking up parts of our application
into separate components in order to
prepare for learning how to build larger
applications and work on applications
with the vue cli outside of a single
html file
let's take a break from the code for a
second and take a look at what we are
going to be building with view
components
we're going to use a simple example of a
form to work on breaking up an
application into separate components
now where you see the red outline those
are each going to be a separate
component
so the outer red outline around the
whole login form
will be its own login form component
and then each input with its label will
be a custom input component that we are
going to create
and be able to reuse for as many inputs
as we have
so we're going to start off with this
outer component and then break out the
inner components into their own
components after that
and then we are going to look at how you
can pass data around between components
in your application
so what would a view component look like
let's say we wanted to have a form in
here
and i'm going to get rid of this
greeting really quick
and put a form here
so i could do this directly in the html
and create a form tag
or i can create a custom tag
as a view component
called custom
form
now this is the same syntax as if it
were an html tag
except of course it is not a standard
html tag so i have to define it as a
view component down here
and i need to define it after
i define
my app variable which is my view
instance
and before i actually mount it to the
dom
so i can chain this here as
app
dot
component
this is a function and it takes two
arguments here that i'm going to pass in
so the first one is the name of the
component that i'm going to use and that
is the name that i'm going to be using
in my html up there so i'll give it the
same name custom form
and the second is an options object
and since this is its own self-contained
component
i can actually use any of the same
options that i've been using here such
as data and methods etc
the only extra thing that i need right
now
is i have to define a template for this
component
and the easiest way to define a template
is by using graves so i can make this
multi-line
and pass in the html here so real quick
i'm going to create a div
and i'm just going to put let's say two
inputs in here for right now
i'll put a type of
email
and then
an input
type
of
password
and let's call this a login form since
we're doing email and password
i'll change that up here to
login form
and since template is the only required
option that i need to pass in on this
object
it should run like it is right now
so let me see if this works i'm going to
go to go live
and you can see these two
form inputs up at the top here
completely unstyled just basic browser
inputs
so i'm gonna style these inputs really
quickly so they're easier to see
after all of these boxes i'm going to
add
a reference to input here
i'm going to say margin of 10 pixels
just on all sides
and a display
of block so they don't go in line
and now they are a bit easier to see
here
all right let me code fold these styles
again
and now let me add a data method to this
component so you can see what that looks
like
so after this template key i have here
i'm going to do the same thing i did
above
with data i'll just use the function
shorthand here
i'll return an object and here i'm going
to give it a title
and the title will be login
form
and now i need to do something with this
title
so up here when i defined variables
i used them inside of my app
template here
but since my login form is a
self-contained component
any variables i define on data here
i am going to have to use them inside
its own template
so i'll just add another line here and
give it an h1
and by the way this doesn't have syntax
highlighting
and is in kind of a weird
template form because i am just doing
this all in one html file this is just a
stepping stone to get to
more standard ways of creating view
components where you will have syntax
highlighting and auto completion and all
of those other great features
so here i need to use that variable
title so i'll use that the same way i
did before by referencing it and now i
should see the title on top of those two
input boxes
and indeed i do here i am
zoomed in quite a bit
so that is the basics of how you can
create a component here
i'm going to go ahead and keep building
out this form and then also show you how
to compose components now
so i'm just going to change this really
quickly to form
and then i'm going to add some submit
functionality here so i'm going to add
event
for submit
submit
and then pass in an argument
with the method i want to run or the
function i want to run when i submit a
form
so i'm just going to call my function
i suppose handle submit
and then i need to make
a methods object down here with that
function
i'll call it handle
submit
and i will just console.log
submitted
so now when the form submits
it will run this function there's a few
more things that i need to do i need to
add a button here that will actually
submit the form
so by default buttons are typed submit
so i don't need to add that here
but i am going to
add some text to the button
now when the form submits it refreshes
the whole page of course this is the
default behavior in browsers so you can
just automatically click and send data
from the form to your back end but since
we are going to be handling the form
submission from our handle submit
function we don't want this default
behavior with the page refresh
so like we saw earlier we have event
modifiers
so we can do
prevent to prevent default this would be
the same thing as passing in an event
object to our handle submit function
and then doing e dot
prevent default
again this is just a shorthand
so now if we look at our console here we
see that it logs submitted
when we submit the form
so now we probably want to be capturing
these inputs
so we can do that again by using the
directive v model
to bind the value of the form input to
a variable we'll call this one email and
we'll remodel
this one as
password
and then add these into data
and now let's log those out
so let's log out email
and
password
of course if you remember i have to get
it off of the this context since i'm
referencing it inside of
javascript here
and now i should be able
to type in something here
this has to be in email
so i'll say gwen at
example.com
just any password
and i'll click log in
and you can see it did log out my
credentials here okay so that's one
component
in the next video let's look at how to
break up this component and take out the
inputs to put them in separate
components
as you saw in the mock-ups earlier in
this video
and we'll also look at how to pass data
between components
so from a parent component to a child
and then also from a child back up to
the parent
so what if we want to compose multiple
components together let's demonstrate
this by removing the inputs and creating
a custom component just for our form
inputs
let's say we want some logic just
contained within a special input
component
so let me fold this real quick
and i'm going to create another
component here i'll do
app.component again
and i'm going to call this custom input
pass in an options object
again i need to have a template here
and in this one i'm just going to have
label
i'm going to display a label variable
here
and then i'll have that wrap around the
input
and i'll use a type
just the default text for right now i'll
change that in a second
and that is a default input
so now where am i going to use this
component so i'm actually going to
replace my input fields
in this component with this new one that
i created
so what i can do here
is
call this custom input
and custom input and i can use my
components inside of this other
component
now there's one more step that i have to
take here
and that is registering the component
so i have to let my login form component
know about the other custom component
and i can do that here by creating
a components array
and then just give it the string of
the component that i want to be using
which is custom input
now let's see how this works
okay so i have these two inputs
now it is giving me this warning that
property label was accessed during
render but it's not defined on the
instance
this is happening because here i'm
referencing this variable label but it
is not defined anywhere so it's giving
me that warning
now i could define a data function here
and create the variable on this
component
but i want to demonstrate passing data
from one component to another so instead
of defining it on this component i'm
actually going to define label
on the parent component and pass it to
the custom input component
to do that
i'm going to come here and add
just a label let me add
in
let me call it email label for right now
and i'm going to call it
email
and i'll also have a password
label
and call this
password
now i have to get these two variables
passed into these custom components here
and so what i'm going to do here i can
go ahead and get rid of the v model for
just a second
and i'm going to add
a label here that i'm going to pass in
and i'm going to pass in the email
label now this looks just like an html
attribute
but i'm actually going to add a modifier
on here
that is a view directive called v
bind
v bind does is basically turn this
regular html attribute
into something that can be parsed as
javascript so that i can pass down a
variable to the child component
so i'm v binding this label which is
email label
which refers to this string here
which is email
this will get passed down as a property
to the child component called label
and now in this custom input child
component
i need to receive that property to
accept it here
with a props object
and the simplest way to write props is
to make an array of strings
just like i did for custom components
and these props are basically just a
list of all of the names of the
information that i'm passing down from
the parent to this child
so now because i'm defining label in
props i will have access to
use the label variable here inside my
template
now if you look at the login form you
can see that the email field
it has a label here and you can tell
it's a label because when i click on the
word email
it focuses on the field it's related to
so let me give a label to password now
too
i'm going to pass in password here
by the way v bind there is also a
shortcut for v bind this is one of the
most common directives in all view
applications so the shortcut is instead
of using v bind colon
you just use colon and then label
so let me pass a label in here as well
so i'll pass a label in
as
label
since we're using this reusable
component
the label will always display as the
label that we pass in
and now you can see that both form
fields are properly labeled here
now i want to point one thing out really
quickly
and that is for
email and these password labels
you could not make variables for these
and just pass them in as strings here so
for example if i get rid of the bind
of the colon shortcut there
then i could just pass in
let's say
password and
let me put enter email here so it's
different
and now i can just pass in this text as
a string
because there's no more v bind here
view is no longer looking for a variable
so now in the application you can see
that it's just passing the string down
as a label to the child component and
displaying that string
i'm going to undo those changes when
you're working in actual view
applications you will see that 95 of the
time
you want to pass a variable in when
you're passing a prop down to a child
component either a data variable or some
kind of a function
so you'll almost always be using this
fee bind syntax here
now there's one issue because in the
child component
we have the input down here we're not
actually listening for changes to the
text in the input we're not v modeling
that to any variable so we don't have
access to whatever is inside the input
so we actually need to create a v model
here
in the child
i'm going to say v model
and just temporarily here i want to map
this to
a variable in the child and i'm going to
just call this input value
and i need to create
a data function here
return an object
with
input
value
as an empty string
so now in this case you're already
familiar with v model and you know that
anytime we type a character into this
input
it's going to update this variable and
this variable and
the input will stay in sync
but now how can i get the value of this
variable up to the parent component here
because i actually want it to stay in
sync with these two variables on the
parent component so that way when i
submit my form
i can have access to it in this handle
submit function
so there are actually a couple different
ways of doing this
i'm going to show you the most
straightforward approach
for getting started with this and then
in future courses
i'm going to explain a little bit more
in depth about how you can use custom
events and other methods of capturing
the value of a variable from the child
to the parent
so to get started here i'm going to use
my same input variable
but i'm going to use a new object here
and this object is called computed
i'm going to comment out data for a
second
so computed is an object
where you can put variable names in here
as
keys
so for example this input value variable
that i want to create
i can put it in here as a key
and whenever this value changes i can
actually get it to run
getter and setter functions
so i can create a getter function
and then
a setter
so when i get the variable
value here
it will run this function and then when
i go to set the
variable value it will run the set
function
so now what value do i want to put in my
getter here i want to get that value
from the parent component
so i'm actually going to
use these two variables that i already
have here
and i'm just going to get rid of these
types i'm not using them yet so
get rid of those
and i'm actually going to do something
different i'm going to create a fee
model directly on my custom component
here and i'll show you why in a second
and i want to model this to the variable
that i'm going to be using so for this
one that is the password variable
and for this one that's email
and these got out of order so i'll
switch them around
okay so now i'm remodeling the email and
password and now i want to get these
variables
in my child component here
now how do i do that so in props
i can actually accept a prop called
model value
and this comes from the parent now it
doesn't really look like we're passing
in another prop because we're not v
binding any variable
and passing it to the child but actually
what v modeling does on a child
component is actually under the hood
it's giving us another prop
called
model
value which is mapped to email
so v model does
a few steps all at once it's kind of a
shorthand here
so
i have access to this model value prop
because i'm using v model
so i can accept that prop in the child
here v model
and then in my getter function i can do
this dot
model value
and i can return that
so now whenever i get the value for this
input
it should be the same as the value in
the parent component
and i can check that by just typing in
some values here
and you can see that the inputs are
pre-populated with the value from the
parent component
because i am v-modeling this input to a
getter function that i'm setting here
and saying that
the value will be
this dot model value which
comes from
the v modeled variable in the parent
component
which are these variables
so now how do we handle setting the
value
if we type text into this input here
so we need to capture the value first
and
view passes this in via a parameter so
we can give this parameter any name that
we want
i'm just going to call it value and i'm
just going to first log out this value
and so here i can try typing in and you
can see it's logging out the value of
the input
from that log in the setter function
but now it's not setting a variable
anywhere
so let me go ahead and set the variable
now to do that i'm going to use a new
method that you haven't seen yet
and that is this dot
dollar sign emit
what omit does
is allow me to emit events that other
components can listen to
and i can pass data around my view
application like that i can emit
events that are built in like i could
emit some kind of on click event or
something like that
or i can omit a custom event that i
create for right now i'm going to use an
event that vue gives me
and this is called an update event
this syntax is actually new slightly
updated in view three
so if you see older tutorials it might
not be using this exact same syntax it
will probably be using an input event
here instead
but i'm gonna pass in a value here
oops i need a comma
so this first argument is the type of
event that i'm emitting
and the second argument is the value
that i'm passing through that event
which is this value that i'm getting
from the input
via the set function
now how can i listen for an event in
another component
i could set this manually but like i
said before v model
is a shorthand so v model is actually
listening
for
this update event from my child
and whenever this update event emits
this v model from the parent component
is updating the value of the variable
for us
let's test this out i'm going to start
typing here
and i'm going to press login
and you can see that it logs out the
values of
the email and password
so this
isn't that clear so let me put a real
email here a real fake email anyway
and you can see there's the email and
there's a password
which are coming from this log statement
in handle submit
now you might be wondering why do we
have to go through all that trouble to
model a variable from a child to a
parent
and the reason why is because the props
that we pass to children
they are immutable we cannot change them
in the child
these variables on data here can only be
changed in the same component
so my custom input can't change
anything we pass in via props here
so for example if i tried to model this
to label here
i'm getting all of these warnings
attempting to mutate prop label props
are read only
so i'm going to undo that
so that's why i had to create this extra
variable in the child
and create a getter so i'm getting this
read-only
model value prop from the parent
and then what i'm doing to update the
value of that prop is i'm omitting an
event to the parent
this update model value event
so the parent because i have this v
model shorthand is listening for that
event
and this component this login form
component is actually updating these
variables itself so i'm not actually
mutating props from the child
now there are definitely other ways of
handling changing props
in the child component
i could listen for changes on this input
and i could call a method
on a methods object
which could do the same thing either
emit an event
i could also pass a function from the
parent to the child
and the child can call functions in the
parent
and then i could update variables in
that way too
there are also other state management
solutions
and we will explore all of these
different options later
i just wanted to give you an initial
taste of how this can be done
in vue.js and specifically in view
version 3 now that the syntax has
changed a little bit
so in this video we've gone over custom
components composing components together
importing them into each other like we
are with this custom input into the
login form component
we also talked about using props passing
data from the parent to the child and
then being able to set data
by omitting an event
that the parent can listen to and
passing it a value
in the next video we are going to talk
about loops
in view to simplify our syntax here with
having multiple of the same component
now let's talk about loops here
we have two of the same component these
custom input components
and i would like to just be able to loop
through as many of these components as i
want
to do this i need to add an array and
data here
and this array will have all of the
information for each input here
including the variable that i want to
model to the label name
and i'm also going to add a type
so i'm going to create an array here
called inputs
and just to demonstrate really quickly
i'm going to add just some strings here
like email
password
and let's say name
so what if i wanted to display all three
of these strings inside the template
here
i'm going to come back to looping over
the form in a second
but for right now i'm just going to
create a p tag here
and i want to show each one of these
strings inside its own paragraph tag
so i'm going to create a loop for these
i'm going to say v4
equals
and then i need to pass in the array
here which is called inputs and this
will loop over the inputs array
now this is a for in loop so i'm going
to have to create a variable that i can
use in the iterations so i'm going to
say for str
short for string
in inputs and now i have access to
this string variable
each time through the loop
and i can basically just display it in a
variable now
right so it is complaining that i made a
mistake in my syntax
and of course that is because i didn't
put a comma
after my array
and now you can see that these top three
here are strings that are displayed in a
paragraph tag
of course they are so big because
i am zoomed in so far
but they are displaying properly and
that is basically how you use a loop in
vue.js
i am missing a prop here that i need to
add
whenever you do a loop you have to add a
key prop here
and this key has to be unique on each
iteration of the loop now the reasons
for using this key prop are a little bit
more advanced
so i'm not going to go in depth on it in
this video
but i just want you to understand that
it is good practice for you to use a key
that will uniquely identify
any elements that you loop through in
your vue.js templates
this can help with performance and
preventing bugs in your applications and
when you move into programming a more
structured view application with view
components in their own files you will
see that your linter and code editor
will pick up on it if you don't have a
key value here and it will give you a
warning and ask you to add one
so we have to have a key to give a
unique reference to each one of these
paragraph tags we're adding into the
template now what i can do since the
names are unique here each string is
different
so i can v bind
to key the string variable str
this is a really simple view application
so you basically don't notice a
difference in the browser but you can
see that there are keys attached to
these elements now
i want to point out though that one more
way that you can create this unique key
every time through the loop
is you can actually get an index through
each iteration of the loop
you can get i here and then use it
as your key and if i print out i
you can see that i is the index of each
iteration in the loop
i put that back as string
so this was just a demonstration of
course so i'm actually going to get rid
of this whole p tag here
and what i really want to be putting in
inputs here are objects
for
the information that has to do with each
input that i want
so the first one let me put a label here
and i'm going to say the label is
email
i'm going to create a value here
and this was what i'm going to v model
to
and then i'll go ahead and add a type
so let's say type is email
and i'll do the same thing for
password
and i can get rid of those now
all right so now my application is
broken because i got rid of all the data
that i had been passing into these
custom inputs
and actually i'm going to get rid of one
of these custom inputs because now i'm
going to be looping over just one
and it will create one
for each iteration of the loop
let me clean this up a little bit
put these on separate lines
and so the first thing i want to do is
create a v4 here
and this v4
will loop through inputs just as i did
before
i'm going to say four inputs in inputs
and i'm actually going to get the index
here really quick as well
and then
use a key of the bind the index
so now i can't v model email
i need to v model based off of this
input object
which is each object in this inputs
array
so i'm going to have to v model input
dot value here to model it to the value
so i'll do input
dot
value
the label also i'm going to have to do
input dot
label
and now i do have a type so let me
rebind a type as well
and i'm going to do input dot type
so that's one thing that i need to
update in this child component now
i'm still accepting that model value
prop and the label prop but i also want
to accept a type prop now and instead of
doing type is text now i have a prop
from the parent based off of which
component it is in the loop
so now i'm going to v bind this so it
can take a variable
and i'm going to say type which will
refer to whatever prop i've passed in
so i'm going to come to my form here
and
i'm going to type in
and i actually forgot to change the
logging here for handle submit
so i don't want to over complicate
things for this example
so what i'm going to do is just delete
this
and
log out this dot inputs
of 0
and that value
and then this dot
inputs
of 1 and then that value
and this should fix my problem here
let me just type something in
and it's complaining that i don't have
an email address so i'm just gonna
type in a fake email
log in
and you can see that it has my correct
login information
so this is the basics of how to handle
loops in vue.js
is you can use v4 either on regular html
elements like an h1 or
any custom components that you make as
well this is very commonly done with
card components if you see a website
like pinterest how it shows all those
different little boxes with pretty
photos in them
if that was built in vjs it would be
doing this v for loop over all of those
data objects that make up all of those
pinterest cards on your pinterest wall
the last thing we need to look at before
we get into the demo application is life
cycle hooks so we will cover those in
the next video
another important concept in vue.js is
lifecycle hooks also called component
life cycle hooks
so what is a hook and what are component
life cycles
to understand this i made a quick demo
similar to the demo that we started off
with in this course i can click the
toggle box button and a box appears
now i'm using a v if to
take this box
at it you can see it was added to the
dom now if i click again it was
completely removed from the dom here
that whole process of
coming into the dom and then finally
leaving the dom
that is the life cycle of this
box component that i have
now sometimes things might leave the dom
because you navigate to another page
or because something is coming into view
via scrolling or because you are hiding
and showing something like this example
in any case you can use something called
life cycle hooks
a hook is just a function that will be
triggered to run
at a specific point in the life cycle of
a component
for example
it's a function that will be called
right when this purple box appears on
the screen
or right before it leaves the screen
if you look at the vue.js documentation
now this is the version 2 documentation
here
because they don't have what i'm going
to show you yet in the version 3 docs
but it is the same thing
so i'm under learn guide
and then if i scroll down on the sidebar
i'm at the view instance and creating a
view instance
and i can actually click on the life
cycle diagram here
so this is a diagram like it says of the
instance life cycle of your view
instance
and like it says you don't need to fully
understand everything that goes on right
now but it is a useful reference
and this chart isn't just useful for
your view instance but every single view
component will have access to these life
cycle hooks
so you can see these two up top in the
red
all of the boxes in the red are the
lifecycle hooks
you can see before create and created
these hooks will be run
right before and right after vue.js has
initialized your component
now the next two before mount and
mounted
the format is run right before your
component is mounted to the dom
and mounted is run as soon as your
components can also go through updates
so before update and updated
like it says here this will happen
or these updates will be triggered when
data changes on your component so any of
those data variables that you create
if you're incrementing a number or
changing some kind of value
then updated and before update will run
and then when your component is going to
leave the dom now here it says before
destroy
and
destroyed now this terminology has been
updated for view three for these two
life cycle hooks
so if we go to
the view three documentation now and
we're on lifecycle hooks here
i'm going to scroll down so you can see
before create created before mount
mounted
before update and updated
i'm going to skip over some of these
and now you can see it's before unmount
and unmounted
which is in place of before destroy and
destroyed
the lifecycle hooks function exactly the
same way they've just been renamed
i hope this will become a little bit
more clear as we look at a demo
so in the code you can see i have the
same box that we used before
up here
and here is the toggle box button
inside of my view template
but this time i do have a special test
box
custom component that i made
which is toggled based off of a v if
so this is my main application and the
options object with my is visible
variable for whether or not the box is
visible and then i just have a toggle
box method which i call
when i click this button so again this
is pretty much the same thing that we
did before except for this new component
here
i put the box in its own component now
now that we've learned about composing
components
and i'm just going to add some life
cycle hooks here really quickly to
illustrate when these are called on the
component life cycle
so i'm just going to add a couple of
them here
i'm going to add created
and then
mounted
and then unmounted
and in each of these i'll put a
console.log
and let's see when these console.logs
print out
back in my browser i'm going to hit
toggle box here
and you can see in the terminal at the
bottom
created printed and then mounted printed
in the same order that we saw in the vjs
documentation so this one happened
before and then this one happened after
it was mounted to the screen to the dom
here
now if i hit toggle box again
we can see unmounted prints because that
is run after the box leaves the dom
now let's look at another one after
methods here
i'm going to
put a life cycle hook on this component
or on the main view instance that we
have here
and i'm going to try updated
and i'll hit toggle box
and you can see that we have created and
mounted those both print from the box
component itself but from the main
instance also updated prints
and that is because we are updating this
data variable from is visible false to
is visible true
and so the update function is triggered
on this component because our data
updated for that component
and if we toggle it again
we can see updated is run again because
that variable was changed to false again
so updated will run every single time
the data changes
now why might you want to use a
lifecycle hook
some of the most common use cases are
checking whether someone is authorized
to view a certain page or component a
lot of people use the created and
mounted hooks as well to pull data into
their application from a back end or
from in browser storage
sometimes they are also used to
initialize events and then when the
component is about to unmount you can
clean up that event or you can save some
data or run some kind of check on before
unmount or in the unmounted function
so those are the basics of life cycle
hooks i encourage you to test out life
cycle hooks on your different components
and see what happens when you use
different life cycle hooks in a future
course we can get into some more
advanced examples and a few of the more
advanced lifecycle hooks as well that
you won't see as often
so those are the basics of vue.js
in the next video we are going to build
a view 3 application from scratch
starting with the vue cli this time
this is a demo of the application that
we will be building it's a simple shop
application with a few items now it
looks like the web page is already done
but actually it's just static html and
css so far as you can see if i click the
add to cart button nothing happens
and if i scroll up the only things that
are actually functional on this site
right now are these top nav links which
are just regular browser anchor tag
links to bring you to another page
so this one goes to the products page
and you can see i have this cart which
is not functional so if i click the x
nothing happens
it's just fully slid out here to demo
how it will look
and if i click the x
nothing happens it doesn't delete the
item i can't add items to the cart
and on this page i have a past orders
table which is also just static content
right now
this project is going to be a little bit
different than tutorials that you are
used to we are not going to be starting
from scratch with some mock-ups here
instead we will be starting with a
static application with html and css
already coded then we will figure out
step by step how to add vue.js into the
application
this will help to give you a deeper
understanding of how vue works and how
to build real-world view
applications first i will give you an
overview of the code base and then we're
going to see how it looks in the browser
and then finally we will start with the
vjs portion and implementing our own
view code into each feature one at a
time
the goal is to eventually reach a point
where it gets to be difficult to
continue to code inside of html and then
we are going to move the project over to
a view cli setup project where we will
have webpack and the full ecosystem of
ujs tooling and libraries like view x
and view router so let's get started
looking at the code
so i'm going to start here with the
package.json
now this is the file that's generated by
npm
you should have seen one of these before
if you've worked with javascript and it
has some metadata about our project here
and then the scripts section
so you don't need to know what all of
these scripts are doing this code will
be available for you so if you want to
dive deeper into each one of these you
can but since we're focusing on view
here the important part is that we have
this start server that compiles our
styles and serves our application for us
now later on i'll show you how to start
an application with the vucli but i had
to use some kind of a temporary server
here in the meantime so that's what live
server is doing for us
it will serve it on a port
similar to what we did with the live
server plugin that we used in vs code
for the last demo application so to
start this application i'm going to go
up to
my terminal option here and i'm going to
choose new terminal and my terminal
opens at the bottom here
inside my current folder
and i'm going to run the start command
so npm start
you can see that automatically opens the
application on the correct port here
and if i scroll down i can see the same
page that you already saw
now back in the code
let's look in the source directory
so the source directory is where
all of our javascript and other code is
going to live
and this is where we'll also be adding
vue.js
this is our main html file for the
application
which is the home page
and you can see the links here go to
views pages inside of this views
directory over here
so the links will take you to the past
orders page and also the products page
now to start working with vue.js i'm
going to start with these cards here
right now i want to be able to update
and save the quantities and be able to
add them to the cart
so in this app.html file i'm going to go
ahead and add my link to vjs just like i
had in the last demo application so i'm
going to go to the bottom here
and paste the script tag so i'm
importing vjs
and now i need to write some custom vjs
code to hook up my application
so i will create another script tag
and here i'm going to do
let app
equal view dot create
app
i'll pass it an empty object for right
now
and then here i'm going to do app.mount
and then
mount it in the same dom element
as before with the id of app
and let me just check here
yes the wrapper div here if i fold it
you can see all of the content is
created inside of app
so to get started here i definitely want
to create a data
method and i need to return an object
and on this object i want to track my
inventory
so when someone clicks the add to cart
button i want to increment or change the
amount of inventory that i have
so inventory itself will be an object
and you can see the different types of
produce that i have here so carrots
pineapples and cherries
and so i'm going to add these three
items to my inventory
carrots
and i'm going to initialize all of these
with zero
that looks good now i need to find these
elements inside my application and put
the variables there
so if i look down at these cards
you can see here's the recommended
product section
so i have carrots here
and i have the price here is the
quantity
with the input field
and what i want to do here instead of
setting the value
i want to do v
model
and this should be
[Music]
inventory
dot
carrots
and then i'm going to copy the same
thing for the other fields
so i'll come down here to pineapples
and
paste this
and then
cherries as well
okay now let me take a look at that
and you can see it still shows zero here
just like before i can update a number
let me do three carats
and now the number starts at three
so now we want to do something when
someone clicks add to cart
if they have a certain quantity in here
we want to add it
to a cart total
let me change this back to zero
so to do that i need to create a method
let me create my methods object
i'll create an add to cart
method
and in this method i need to take in the
number of
items
that someone wants to add to their cart
and also the type of item so
to do this i'm going to need
another place to store what items are
actually in the cart
so i'm going to create a cart here
and for right now i'm just going to copy
the same items over
and then when i call the add to cart
method i need to pass in the type of
item
and the
quantity then i can access my cart
variables by doing this dot cart
and to pass in a variable that i want to
access on my cart object
i need to use the square brackets and
then i can pass in type so it would be
the same as this dot cart dot carrots or
this dot card.pineapples
or whichever item we want to access and
then i'm going to increment by the
quantity
so plus equals
now i don't have to return anything from
this function because this is really the
action that i want to take by calling
this function
is to update whatever i have in my cart
right now
and to show this i'm just going to log
this out in the console
in the browser so you can see it
i'm going to log out this dot cart
and i'm going to open my console here
so for carrots i'm going to add three
you can see nothing happened
that is because i forgot to connect this
method to that button
so let me go up here and add
that button
so i'm just going to add it to
carrots right now
here
so when someone clicks on the add to
cart button
i'm going to call the add to cart
method
now i need to call it passing in
a few arguments here so the first one
is going to be the type of item that i
want to add to the cart
so this one will be carrots
and i also need to pass in
the quantity
to pass in the quantity i need to use
the inventory.carrots variable
so i can just pass that in here
i could also just call it from inside of
my function
which is actually what i'm going to do
so let me scroll down to see my function
again
and instead of quantity here instead of
passing in this extra variable
i'm going to just update this to
this dot
this dot inventory
and then
get the type from there
so let's see if this is working
let me
add to cart
and you can see there is definitely a
problem because
the input value is a string and it's
trying to add it
to the number zero so then it turns the
expression into a string
now vue has a very easy way of fixing
this
and this is through a modifier just like
we learned about a little bit in the
last demo that we did
so let me go up here
to the v model
and we don't want this v model to be
considered as a string we want to go
ahead and cast it as a number
so vue gives us this modifier as a
shortcut
so
v model dot number
so now if we look in our application let
me add to cart and i can see
down here
that my carrots have one item in it
which is a number so i can add the card
again and now it's two
and i can add multiples and now there's
eight carrots in the cart
let's stop here for this video and don't
forget to download the related code and
try out these features for yourself
in the next video we will work on
displaying the items in the cart
so now we want to hook up this cart menu
or cart slide out
and right now it's just static content
so we can only see it from the products
page
and if you look at the code we go to the
products.html
going to fold this header
and also the main container
which is this main part of the page
right here
and now i can just see this aside which
is that cart section on the side
so i basically want to get all of this
html
and make it available on my other pages
like my app page which is the home page
so that i can use vue.js to trigger
opening or closing the menu
and i also want to make these cart items
dynamic
so when i add more items to the cart it
can update the quantity and the price
and i can also set a variable so if
there are no items in the cart this will
display
now html itself doesn't have something
like an import to import a block of html
into another html file
a lot of people use php or some other
backend tool for that but we can also
easily do this in javascript
so we're going to do this in vjs
actually
so i'm going to remove this sidebar
from the page that it is on right now
and move it into our view application
of course our view application is nested
inside of the app.html page
but we can move it outside later
so that this menu will be accessible on
all pages in the future
so i'm going to fold
this view.create app and now i will
paste
this html aside that i have
now it's giving me an error or a couple
errors right now because it's inside of
a script tag but i'm going to fix that
so if you recall
in the earlier lessons we defined
different components
inside of our view application
so this is a perfect use case for a
component right now because it's this
reusable block of html
or template that we want to use on
multiple different pages and also
interact with
so i'm going to
register this as a component
and
i'm just going to call it sidebar
and now i pass in the object just as
before
and on this options object
i can set the template
and then
use
graves and now i want to grab
this aside again
and
paste it inside of here
and so now i have this hole aside all of
the code
inside of my template for this component
and now i can add this to the page with
the name sidebar
so i'm going to go ahead and add it here
and remember that our div wraps the
whole view application so i can put this
anywhere inside of that div with id of
app
i'm going to put it here actually
between the main
and the footer
i'm going to put the custom
component
sidebar
and view will handle putting the
template i have down here
where this sidebar element is in the
template
so let me go back
to the html here you can see the sidebar
is no longer on the products page but if
i go to the home page
now i have a sidebar here
so now that the sidebar is in view js i
can start making it interactive
and the first thing i want to do is be
able to hide and show the sidebar
so basically when this is clicked i want
to hide it and then when another button
is clicked i want to show it
so i need to create a variable for this
and let me go down to
my javascript down here
so inside of my regular create app here
and my main options object i'm going to
add
an element to data here
and i'm going to call it show
sidebar
false
and now i can come to my sidebar and
simply
use a v if
and point it to the variable show
sidebar
so if show sidebar is true
then my custom component will show up on
the page
if it's false then i shouldn't see the
sidebar at all
and you can see it's false i don't see
any sidebar
and when i change this to
true
i see the sidebar
now i just need to add a toggle for this
sidebar let me change it back to false
by default
and now i can create a method
called
toggle
sidebar
and i'm going to say this dot show
equals the opposite of whatever it is
because it will toggle true or false
every time this function is run
so i'm going to say it equals not this
dot
show
sidebar
so if it's currently false that means it
will be set equal to true and if it's
true it will be then set equal to false
now i just have to call this method
so the first place that i'm going to put
it
is on this button here this cart button
should open that cart sidebar
i'm going to find that on the page
here is that cart button
and i'm just going to add an app click
here
add click
equals
toggle
sidebar
i don't need to pass anything in so i
can just leave it as this and view will
automatically look through my methods
and find that method so let me see if
that works let me go back to the page
should be able to click on this now
and yes it does toggle now the next
thing i need to be able to do is close
it and i need to close it using this x
here
so i'll have to go down to
my template here
and here is the button that's that x
that's in the corner of the header for
the sidebar
so i need to add an act click on this
and i'll have to do at click
and now i want to use the function
toggle
sidebar
but because this is wrapped in its own
component i actually don't have access
to the toggle sidebar function from here
i actually have to pass it into this
component to be able to access it
and i can do that here
so i'll pass it in as toggle equals
toggle sidebar
i'm using my method on the vjs object
called toggle sidebar passing it into
the sidebar component with the name
toggle
so inside
my component here
it's going to be called toggle
so i'm going to have to accept it as a
prop
and i'll accept it as toggle and that
will be my function name so now i have
to rename this function
and call it toggle
let me see if this works go to cart
click x and it is not working
so i do have an error here maximum call
stack size exceeded so let me see what i
did wrong in the code
so i'm importing the prop toggle
the function should be called from here
i've toggle sidebar
that is pointing to toggle sidebar here
and
oh i forgot to make this
point to a view variable
instead it was just trying to use it as
a string before which was causing an
error
so now it should be calling the actual
toggle sidebar function
and let me see that in the code
okay it works just as intended now
so now on the sidebar i want to be
displaying actually dynamic items here
for right now i only have one item
hooked up carrots
and so i'm only going to be working with
this one item
until the next video so let's hook this
item up when i add items to the cart
here
i should it should update in the cart
over here
now to do that
i need to take this cart object and pass
it in to my sidebar so my sidebar has
access to it
first let me do some
cleanup here
put this on multiple lines to make it a
little bit cleaner
and i'm going to pass in cart as just
cart
and now i have to receive this prop
in my component here
so i'm going to do it here
and call it cart
and now cart that i'm getting in my
component is actually that cart object
so since i'm only working with carrots
for right now
i'm going to just assume that
and only add the number here for carrots
so
i'll use my
double mustache syntax
and i have that cart variable so i'll do
cart dot
carrots and that will be the number of
carrots that i have
so let me go back to here
and it automatically updated let me add
three
and
my cart now has quantity three
so if i add let's add five more now
there's quantity eight in my cart so now
my cart is dynamic
of course the total should also be
updated based off of the quantity it
should be price times quantity equals
the total for that item
so let me do that really quickly this is
the total number
so i'm just going to have to
do this
and let's say
cart dot carats
times
the price which it says it's one dollar
but here it says 482 so i'm going to use
this price because one dollar
isn't that interesting
so i'll do times 482
and then before that
i need to put in dollars
and let's see if that works
two add to cart
now there is an error let's see what the
error is
unexpected token with a dot
the reason why it's complaining is
because a dollar sign followed by curly
braces in javascript whenever you put
that syntax inside of the back ticks
that we have around this template here
it's called a template string
and it will parse whatever is inside
those outer curly braces as javascript
so it thinks we're trying to pass in a
javascript object and it's complaining
because cart dot carrots is not a valid
key
so the only thing we have to do here is
actually escape the dollar sign so
javascript doesn't think we're trying to
use a template string and pass in a
variable
and then vue can just parse the double
curly brace syntax on its own
this should work
so let me go to cart now my cart opens
as normal you can see there's zero
carrots and now if i add
two carrots to the cart
and now gives me the correct total of
now i also want to have a total of all
the items in the cart i only have one
item now but i will have more items soon
so i'm going to go ahead and add a
function for that and then we will hook
up the rest of the items in the next
video
so back in the code here
this is the total that i want to update
so i'm going to add this and escape that
dollar sign that comes before the double
curly braces
now i could create a formula just in
line here and say
cart dot carrots times the carrot price
plus
the second item times that price and so
on and so on but that's not going to
make a lot of sense and that doesn't
scale for multiple items
so what i'm going to do here
is actually add a computed
object
and if you remember computed watches the
changes in variables and will update the
result
so i'll call this computed function
cart
total
and on my cart up here
right now i have
just the number of each item so for
right now i'm just going to hard code
the price
down here
so i'm going to return
cart dot
carrots
times
the price which is 482
and now i can take this computed
variable that i created
and put it in here
and now the cart total that amount
should be updated every single time
let's see if this works add to cart
open my cart and there is a bug because
it's not opening
i'm stepping through trying to figure
out why the cart total isn't working
and
it is because i have accessed it
incorrectly
so
cart dot carrots
has to be accessed this is inside of
javascript so i need to access it on the
this context in my component
so i have to access it on this dot cart
dot carrots and that should come up with
my number times that number
so let me go back to my page
and now it opens and
if i add items
i can see it's twenty four dollars and
ten cents
of course this isn't that pretty
sometimes it rounds it to 1 or sometimes
there's only one decimal and sometimes
there's like 10 here
so let's just round this really quick
using something built in in javascript
so we just get two decimals
i'm going to wrap this here
dot to
fixed
and then the number two
and let's go back to the browser
i'm going to open up the cart
add a few items
and now it's at two decimals exactly
always two okay
i'm going to leave it there in this
video
again please try out implementing these
features on your own from the example
code you should be able to check out the
starter branch called home page one from
the repository
and start exactly where i did at the
beginning of this video in the next
video we will cover adding all of the
rest of the items to the cart by
importing them into our javascript so we
can use loops to make our code more
efficient and not have to hard code
everything
in this video we are going to pull in
dynamic content to populate our page
and that will be from this food.json
file
so this actually has a list of objects
of all different kinds of groceries that
we are going to display in our app
it has some information like the names
as well as the price and then even if we
want to add a filter to sort by the type
so how can we pull this into our
application
actually we are going to use lifecycle
hooks in vue.js for this
if we come to
our main view application here below
methods i am going to add a mounted hook
just like we had before
and inside of here i am going to fetch
this json data and that's going to be an
asynchronous call
so i first need to fetch this
from
the file name which is food.json
and i'm going to call this
the response
and then i need to call the json method
on that response
which i'll put on this line and that
will be data
and actually i need to add a weight to
these calls
so
res.json i can call that method
i'm going to await this as well and then
because i'm using a weight i need to add
async
to this mounted
method
so now i've created the mounted
lifecycle hook
i get my data which is the array of all
of the food objects
and now that i have my data i am going
to set it on state here
so instead of inventory here i'm going
to replace inventory
just get rid of all this
dummy data
that i have right now
set it as an empty
array
this will definitely break my
application right now but it's okay
because it's a step toward fixing it
so
now i'm going to set this dot inventory
equal
to data
let's see if that even works
and i'm going to come
to my view here
i can see my root
and i can see that
the inventory
in my root element here
that i have all 15
items
good so i know my data is working now
the next two things i need to do
are display that data on this page here
and so these are just three recommended
items
actually all of the products
will display on this page
so for the home page i'm just going to
display the first three and slice that
list
as i loop over it
so now that i have inventory i'm
actually going to come up here to
my main container
and i'm going to come to the recommended
section
[Music]
and fold all of these cards
and get rid of the last two because i'm
only going to need one
for my loop
and now with this initial card i'm going
to turn it into a v4 loop
and loop over each item in that
inventory array
so
equals
product
in inventory
let me just see what this looks like
really quick
and yes it tries to loop through
every single item in the whole inventory
so i'm going to slice it at three items
now
and i can do this because inside of my
view directive i can put valid
javascript so
i'm going to do dot
slice
from 0 to 3.
and now i'll go back to my page
and you can see i only have three items
now
of course it is only displaying carrot
because that's all still hard-coded
so let me put some dynamic content in
here
and first with the name
i am going to put
product dot name
and then i believe it's product dot
type yes
so here
i'll put
product dot type
and for the price now i do have prices
in two different currencies i'm just
going to use us dollars for right now
so i need to access price
usd
and so here i'm going to go ahead and
escape this
and then
do
product dot price
dot us
d
and actually this is just an html
template this isn't inside of a
javascript template string so i don't
need to escape that at all
and that should be all of the dynamic
content that we need for right now let's
actually go ahead and update the icon as
well
so that would be product dot
icon
and make sure that's the right
one
yes dot icon
okay so let me go to the page
okay so the icon's not working but
all the other data is displaying quite
nicely
so now we want to add functionality so
that the quantity properly updates and
we can add it to the cart
of course right now
all of these elements have the same v
model so that's why they are mirroring
each other so let's change that
now i'm going to go to the v model
here which is inventory.carrots
but i need the inventory of the correct
item instead of just hard-coding carrots
here
so
because these numbers are in order or
because this is an ordered list
i'm going to come to my loop
and get the index
of course
i could use the id as well but i'll just
use the index in the loop here
and actually i almost forgot i also need
to add
a key here since i am looping
so let me add that key
and i'm going to come down here
and in inventory
i'm going to pass in that index
and then i'm going to add a new
attribute called quantity
and so this should model to an attribute
called quantity
which is not currently
on the objects but that's okay i'll just
leave it off
and this should just add the quantity
key to the object as needed
so let's see if this works let me go
back over here
i'm going to add one here you can see
they're not all mirrored for each other
anymore i'm going to add it to cart
and let me see how this represents in my
view data here
i can come to inventory
and i can see quantity of one
whatever number i put this number
mirrors it but now i need a way to add
this to the cart
so let me set up the cart then
and here at this add to cart function i
do need to change it because i need to
pass in
instead of a string
the dynamic name of the item
so i can do product dot name
and actually here i didn't think of this
but instead of inventory and getting the
inventory at index i
i already really have that in this loop
that's what the product variable is
so i'm just going to replace that and
that should work just fine
now of course i don't really need
this index anymore because
for the key
i can use
the id of the product so let me just use
that product.id
and that should work okay
and then this should also mirror for
object two let me see if that does
yes and the quantity is mirrored
okay now for the cart
i'm passing in the product name as add
to cart let's take a look at the add to
cart function
we are passing in the type here
and then saying this.card.type so it
will be like this.cart.radishes
plus equals whatever the amount is at
this dot inventory
so we do need to do one more thing here
we could either search and find the item
by name in the inventory
or the easier thing to do would be to
pass in
the index of that item
so that's what we're going to do
and while i'm changing this
instead of type now i think it makes
more sense to call it name
because it is the name of the item
and we are using type for the type of
item like vegetable or fruit not the
name anymore
so now to access it in inventory i want
to do index and then dot
quantity
and that should work but we have to
actually pass in the index here
and up here we're actually going to be
passing in
the index actually
so
i'm going to take the index here
and now
add the cart
okay
so we're getting not a number for these
values
so i actually want to see what we are
passing in or what gets passed in
to the function
and so to debug the function quickly i
am just going to
console.log name and index
now back in the code
so the
arguments are getting passed into the
function just fine
so stepping back through this i can see
that my problem here
is that
i am doing a plus equals
on cart
or
cart dot name
when there is
no value for that name in the cart yet
and by the way i'm going to go ahead and
get rid of my dummy data in the cart
and here i'm just going to put a simple
check so if
not
this dot cart
name
then i'm going to set this cart
name and equal to zero
and now this statement should work
okay let me try again
so here i'm gonna do two
and this should update
let's see
okay yes
it's just taking a minute for some
reason but it shows the correct number
of each in the cart no more not a number
now that shows it on the cart over here
i want to show it in the sidebar
right now the sidebar is hooked up to
only look for carrots so let's make the
sidebar dynamic now
so if you remember the sidebar here is
in this template so it's part of the
custom sidebar component that we made
and we are already passing the cart in
here now we actually need more
information because the cart is only
showing us the number of items in the
cart
but we also want more information from
those items such as the price
so i'm going to come up here
to my sidebar
and after cart i'm going to be passing
in
the inventory as well
as inventory
and now i can receive that as a prop in
my component
so basically we have to loop through all
of the items in the cart and display
their information now
and we have a table here so we have all
of the headers for the table
and then we can loop through these rows
and basically make as many rows as we
want
so i'm going to go ahead and add a v4
here
to
loop through each item
in the cart
and here i do need to
use the index i will be using that as a
key here
okay and now these are being looped
through in the sidebar
so if i come to the sidebar i should see
no items right now
of course the total needs to be fixed
and now i can see i have this item
and now i have another item
so now i need to get rid of these
hard-coded names
now to do that i'm going to go ahead and
grab the key
for these items in the cart and actually
because cart is an object this index is
actually going to be a key and then the
third one is index
or just i
so
now i have access to
the item name which is the key
the item quantity which i will change
this to the name
quantity
and here i can change this
to that key and we should see the names
of all of the items in our cart
let's test this out
let me add different items to the cart
should see radishes and artichokes
and in the cart we do indeed see
radishes and artichokes
now let's display the quantity
so here we can get rid of
this and say
just
quantity
which we're pulling off of the object in
the cart
of course we already know that should
work let me add an item here
and quantity works
now price is a little bit trickier
because we don't have the price stored
on the cart we actually have to search
through inventory for the price
so we're going to make a helper method
for that
first let me escape this
and then we're going to call get price
pass in the name of the item which is
the key
and we will find the price and return it
based off of the name
so after computed here i'm going to add
methods for this
just a regular methods object
and add that get price
and basically we can access this dot
inventory and do a dot find
so we want to find one of the inventory
items
so
i'll call each item product
in the function that i pass in
and dot find will loop through all
products in the inventory and try to
find whatever item i want
so i want the item where the product
name
is equal to the name that i'm passing
into the function
and when i find that product
i'm going to set it equal
to a variable here
it's kind of confusing
if i
call it product again so maybe i'll just
call this one p instead
there we go
and now for the return function now that
i have the product
saved in this variable
i can do
product
and it should be dot price dot usd again
so dot price dot usd
and that should return the price of the
item and let's see if that works
so let me get one here
and view the cart
and i can indeed see the price let me
try that for artichokes too
and i can see the price and quantities
of the item correctly
now let me update the function for total
and so total here needs to be dynamic
based off of the whole cart really
so to do this i'm actually going to use
a helper method so what i'm going to do
is take
this out of computed
and instead use it as a method
so since it's not computed it's a method
i'm going to call it
a verb so calculate total
and i'm going to go ahead and rename
the method call down here of course i'll
actually be calling that as a function
now
and
i won't be needing this line of code
anymore
so now we basically need to calculate
the total
based off of
the quantity in the cart and then we
have to look up the price in the
inventory
fortunately we already have a method to
be able to look up the price
so we're going to just use that
and the easiest way to do this is
actually to do
object dot
values
and so object.values can give me an easy
array of values out of an object
and because cart
is an object
i'm not going to loop through it
directly i'm just going to grab all of
the values out
so i will pass in cart and now i have an
array of all of the values here
which are the quantities that i want
so out of that array i'm going to reduce
it
now the reduce function is just a
built-in javascript function
where i save an accumulator
some people like to call it a sum
i'll call it accumulator because that's
what it uses on mdn
and basically i'm calculating a sum on
each iteration through the loop
i also have my
current item
that's being looped through
and then i can also get the index of
that item
in the function
and basically what i want to do
is return
the accumulator
sum total whatever you want to call it
plus
the current item or the current value
because i'm looping through all of the
values on the cart here
and i need the value times the price
so i'm going to have to
call
dot get price and then i need to pass in
the
name of the item that i want to get the
price for
so
the easiest way to do that is to also
make an array of names so
i'm going to do that by using this time
object dot keys
and i will do this dot cart
get all of the keys this time off of
cart and actually i forgot to put this
here
and so i will do the current value times
this dot get price
and now that i have the names here i'm
just going to look up by the index
so
i can pass in names index
to the this dot get price function and
that should work
for the function i forgot to put an
arrow here
and now for the total variable
i just stored it in a variable
to explicitly name it all i need to do
now is return the total
now this function works there might be a
more optimized way to do this
this is just to demonstrate how to
calculate a total using a vjs method for
this application
and it's basically just using
regular javascript so let me add items
to the cart here
and of course of course this total we
haven't done yet
but we do have two radishes and the
total says two dollars
so let's add some artichokes and now we
have a total of
30 dollars and 32 cents as you can see
those aren't the correct values what i
believe is happening is because objects
are unordered
and arrays are ordered
that the names
and
the
object.values they aren't being listed
in the array in the same order
so i'm going to have to instead of
making two separate arrays here i'm
going to get rid of this one
and here i will just have to change this
to entries
and now my current value here will
basically be
in array
that will be the
key and the value
each time looping through
this larger array
so
for the value now i will have to access
it
at the first index
and
instead of names here i can access the
name
at
the current item at the zeroth index
that all looks good the last thing i'm
going to do is add an initial value here
and this means that the accumulator will
start at zero
and also if there are no items in this
array
which there aren't any to start that
means the number will just be zero total
and for here for the total actually i'm
going to use that method again
that we used before
which was two fixed so i could do it to
two decimals which is what i want in my
cart
let me see if this works
and this is exactly what i want here
so let me add
items
yes and the price is exactly right
one artichoke
and the price still works there
now what about the total here
that should be easy enough to do with
our get price method
so let's go down to the total right now
it's hard coded as carrot switch doesn't
exist
so
now i can do
just
the quantity
which is the quantity of the item in the
cart
and then i'll call
the get
price method
and i'm going to pass in the key which
is the name of the item
and so that should multiply by the total
let's see if that works
let's add an item and check out the cart
and we do indeed see the total here
now it still says no items in cart let's
go ahead and fix that
so this should only show if in fact
there are no items
and so i'm going to add a v if here
and just to speed this up we're going to
do object
dot keys
and then check the cart object
so if there are no keys on the cart
object that will be zero which is a
falsie value
and let's see if that works
let's go down here
to radishes
add one
in the cart
we are still seeing this no items in
cart
so i believe i have to do
length here and let's see if that works
okay
that does work but i have it backwards
so i basically
need to do if
not
because if the length is zero
i want to show this and if it's not zero
then i don't want to show this no items
in cart because there will be items in
the cart so
let's see if that works
let's first go here it does show no
items in cart
and now let me go here
and now it changes to the item in the
cart and all of the totals are shown
correctly
and the quantity is updated and all of
that stuff
the only other thing i want to do is
provide full crowd operations and this
delete does not work
so i'm going to hook up the delete now
so you can see the delete is here on
this button for remove
and so i'm going to add a function here
and actually this function will have to
be not inside of this component but
inside of the parent component which is
my main view application in this case
so i'm going to do
a click so when this button is clicked
i'm going to say remove
item
to remove the item from the cart and
then i need to pass in the name of the
item which is the key
now this remove item
is going to have to be a function passed
in as a prop here because i can't mutate
prop so i couldn't change the inventory
or the cart actually directly from this
component i have to change it from the
parent component where it originates
so i'll take a remove item function let
me go ahead and pass that in
remove
item
equals remove
and now i have to create that function
here as one of these methods
so let me add that remove
item
this will take in the item name
and i am going to remove it from the
cart basically so i can just remove
javascript delete
this dot cart
name
let's see if that works
let me
add some vegetables to my cart
and now i will remove them
and it does not remove let's see if i'm
getting an error
remove item is not a function so let's
see why it's not considered a function
i do have it in methods here remove item
let's go here this is remove item
that i'm passing into my sidebar
i'm also accepting it as a prop in the
sidebar here
let me get rid of computed
so it's not recognizing this as a
function
so what i'm going to do is rename it in
the child component now this is a
workaround only for the cdn you won't
have this problem if you were using
vue.js from npm
but i'm just renaming the function in
app.component here
there we go
and of course i need to pass it in as
the name remove so i basically gave it a
different name
for the child component and for the
pairing component and let's see if it
recognizes this as a function now
i will come here
and
i can remove it from the cart awesome of
course when i add things to the cart i
do want the number to clear here so let
me take care of that really quickly
in add to cart here
just really quickly i'm going to
set this to zero
let's see if that works
and back to zero and
it is in the cart now
awesome
the only other thing
is that the cart does show zero items
even when there are items in it that's
because the number is not dynamic
so let me change that really quickly
here inside of the parentheses i'm going
to change this to be dynamic
and i'm just going to call the variable
total
quantity
okay and now i need to make this
variable
so what i'm going to do
is create a computed
object here
and i'm going to say
total
quantity
is basically the sum of all of the
quantities in the cart
and to do this i'm going to use another
reduce method
i'm going to say
object
dot values
pass in this dot cart and then
i will reduce those
to sum up all of the numbers
so i have my accumulator and my
current value
and then all i need to do is
add
the accumulator and current value
together
of course i'll set a default of 0 here
as a starting point or initial value
and i'm just going to
return this directly this time
let me see if that worked
right now it says zero
but let me add
items now it's three
let me add one more
and now it's four so the quantity is
working
if i remove one now it's just one so
that is a dynamic value now
and that is basically it for the home
page here
in the next video we are going to move
the vjs code outside
of the app.html file so we can see how
it can work in multiple different pages
and also some of the struggles that we
might run into trying to
build a multi-page site via the vue cdn
and trying to do things like share data
across pages and stuff like that
if you want to see the starter code for
this video make sure you check out the
branch in the repo called home page
number two or home page two
hi everyone welcome back
first i want to review what we did in
the last video
we connected the cart slide out draw
menu on the right here
and made that fully functional and then
we added an actual loop
as well as functionality to be able to
add items to our cart here now this is
only one page of course so we also have
the products page here so if i go to
products page you can see the url
changes
to go to the products.html page
now if i look at this in my code so let
me open up the source
and this app.html file again
you can see here is the header with all
of the links on it
i'm going to fold that real quick and
then you can see the different sections
of the page including that sidebar that
slides out that we actually want on
every page but now it's kind of just
hard coded into this home page
i can also go to views here so you can
see in the header actually so when i
click on products it goes to views
products.html
so it's actually navigating me to this
products.html page
and if you look at the header here
here's the whole page
including a completely separate div with
id of app
where we would have to inject our vue.js
code
you can see we already did that on this
page because our vue.js is in the script
down here
and we are
rendering it or mounting it inside of
that div
but if i go to products we have no
javascript
no interaction everything is hard coded
we also have a duplicate header
so this is exactly the same thing as
the header on
this page
is just copy pasted into the html on
of course we don't want to do that
everywhere
we don't want to have a copy pasted
header for all of our different pages
not only that we would have to copy
paste the whole cart sidebar as well
so to make this code reusable here
we need to extract these things into
other files
now this is not easy to do
for plain html
but we can use a view component like we
did before
with the sidebar
so i'm actually going to extract all of
this out
into a separate javascript file
and now import this file into my html
and you can see my page is still working
my cart is still fully functional
and what this allows me to do
is now take this file this javascript
file that i have separated and imported
also into my products.html file
and i'm actually going to grab
both of these script tags so i can also
have my view
and i'm going to put them at the bottom
here
except i'm going to have to go up a
directory here
because my app.js file
lives outside of my views right
here's products and i need to get up one
folder to app so i have to do dot dot
and that should reference the correct
app.js file
let me see if that's working
if i go to products and you can see the
cart page doesn't open but that's
because i have not hooked up the cart
button yet
so
i will have to copy this over from the
app.html file for right now
so if i go here
i can
just take the same code
and now it should reference that same
toggle sidebar function
and also display the total quantity
correctly as well because i am importing
the same vue.js code in the script tag
here
now you can see that the cart variable
displays just fine on the products page
but if i click here of course the cart
doesn't open
because the cart is only available
on this page
i only have the sidebar component here
and the sidebar component
you know is actually
a custom component that we made in vjs
so we can put that on any page where we
import the vjs
so i'm just going to put it here below
this main tag
and with all the same variables those
should be fine because we're sharing the
same vue.js script
let me save that
now you can see i can toggle the cart
here
and all of this is pretty much the same
thing that we did on the home page down
here where we looped through
the different types of foods
we would do the same thing over here on
the products page
loop through them hook up each
individual number
then hook up the add to cart button so
that it would actually display in the
cart over here
now if i add items here
let me add a couple to cart you can see
i have three in my cart here
if i go to products you can see the page
refreshed and now there are no items in
my cart
so though there is some functionality to
this application so far there are a few
problems that we have run into
with just using a cdn to import vjs
and that is how do we share data across
pages and across pager refreshes
so here at the home page
when i add something to the cart here
it leaves the car as soon as the page
refreshes
so as soon as i navigate to another page
it's gone
now how would i fix that problem
so generally in front end applications
we would want to do something like
persist our data or save our data
somewhere one easy way to do that in the
browser one very common way
is to go here in application and you can
see there's different types of storage
this is in browser storage
and local storage will persist even if
the page is refreshed
so we can actually save
the data like our cart data
into local storage here and then if we
refresh or anything we will just
automatically try to pull
anything that's saved from local storage
for the way our application is set up
right now that would be every time we
navigate to a new page we would have to
check local storage see if there's
anything in there and then pull it into
our application
it's kind of a work around for our setup
so one way to fix this would actually be
to create a single page application with
view where the front end would actually
do the routing instead of our server in
this case we're just using a live server
in vs code
but our server is serving up pages every
time we go to a new url here and that's
why it has to refresh because it's
coming from the server whereas if we
make a single page application there
will be no page refreshes we will go
seamlessly from page to page
because our front end in other words vjs
will be routing us two different pages
the second problem as you can see is
sharing code
we do have some duplicate code across
pages
of course we are reusing the same
sidebar
template here this sidebar template we
just registered it as a view template
a view component called sidebar and we
can use that on any page now we could do
the same thing with header as well
and we would probably do that
if we were going to build an application
using the cdn we could extract this into
a template as well
and then we would have to do the same
thing for the past orders page
of course none of this is dynamic or set
up yet but the easiest thing to do is
actually to set up our project with
something called the view cli
as our code base grows it will be very
difficult to manage many different
components if we are managing them just
importing different files into all of
our different html files
but there is a much easier way
and that is with the view cli this is
why it was created
the view cli basically gives us one
command
view create
and our project name
and then it creates a whole project for
us
it walks us through
a setup wizard
asks us what features we want and then
we'll create all of the files folders
and build tools necessary for a robust
front-end single page application
so in the next video we are going to
take all of our code currently in html
files and our javascript file
and convert it to a view cli application
i'll see you in the next video
let's get started with the vue cli i am
at cli.vjs.org
and i'm just going to click getting
started
and if i go over to the side click on
installation
i can see that it is prompting me to
globally install
this view cli package at view
cli
so that from my command line or terminal
i will be able to use a view command to
create projects
now you might see some places on the
internet that install a different
package
without the at sign and slash just view
dash cli
or something like that that is an older
version of the package
view basically has its own name space
and then each one of its packages
are after the forward slash so to
install vue cli
you can copy this command here
i'm going to go to my terminal
and now i have the vue cli installed
i can check and make sure that it's
installed
by checking the version
right now i have version 4.5 4.5.11
and now i want to use it to create an
actual view project
and i can do this through the view
create command
and then give it the name of the project
that i'm going to create
if you want to see the documentation for
this command
you can come over here under basics to
creating a project
and read about how view create works
here
i'm going to go ahead and say view
create
product
and cart
as the name of my project
and click enter
now if you've used some tools like
create react app you will notice that
here
it's a little bit different it doesn't
just bootstrap the whole project for you
right away
you actually get to pick your own
options
and the packages that you want to
install and use
these top four options here are actually
custom options that i have created
myself view gives us these two defaults
right now one is for version two of view
and one is for version three
and then it also gives us the option at
the bottom to manually select features
so i'm going to go ahead and do that
just to show you how it works
so i basically use the arrow keys to go
down and then i can click enter
when i want to select something
now you'll notice that this list here is
multi-select
and if i press space bar
i can select or deselect an item
of course i want to choose my view
version because i want to use version
three
i definitely need to have babel set up
for me for transpiling my view code
i'm going to need routing in this
application
i'm also going to use state management
with view x
but i'm going to add that later to show
you how to add a view cli package after
you've already set up your application
css preprocessors are things like sas if
you think you will want to use sas in
the future it's a good idea to go ahead
and set it up now i believe this also
works with less and stylus as well
and then i definitely want linting and
formatting in this project
and i can optionally select testing if i
want which but i'm not going to do that
this time so once i'm ready i'm going to
hit enter it takes me to the next step i
can choose the version of vjs
arrow down
and i'm going to choose version 3.
use history mode for the router this is
a pretty small coding change but it's
usually what you want in a project this
basically only affects the url of your
project from a user point of view so if
you want your routes to be after a
hashtag
it will use hash router
if you want your routes to be after just
a normal forward slash like any website
you would navigate to in your browser
then you can just go ahead and use
history router and i'm going to use
history router now it's asking me to
pick a linter in formatter so i'm going
to go ahead and pick eslint plus the
standard config that it has for vjs
click enter
i'll lint files when they're saved
i'm going to choose to put my
configuration in the package.json this
time just so i don't have a bunch of
extra config files
usually when you have larger projects
you want dedicated config files so it's
not cluttering up your package.json
do i want to save this as a preset
no i do not this time but if you
remember at the beginning of this
walkthrough the four top options those
were presets that i had saved in the
past but here i'm just going to say no
here it's basically
setting up my whole project with the
file structure and everything
and it's also running an npm install
you can see it successfully created my
project
if i list the folders inside now i have
this new folder that was created for me
by vue.js called product and cart
i'm going to go into that folder
and you can see when vue spun up the
project for me it also initialized a git
repository for me and saved all of the
changes that it did initially as a
commit
so let me open this up in vs code
and i have my complete project created
for me by view in the next video we will
look through all of these folders and
files and give you a little bit of a
tour of how your view project is laid
out
let's look at all of these files and
folders that vue spun up for us
now looking at this this looks pretty
much like the last project
that we worked on with static html css
and javascript files
and that was by design
to give you the same style of coding and
file structure that you would be using
in a real view application
this however is much much nicer
starting with the view cli gives us a
lot more features out of the box though
we can see in the package.json we have
three scripts here by default there
would be more if you choose to install
the testing packages as well
because we installed a linter the vcli
gives us this lint command
and then it also gives us our main two
commands for the view application
for development locally
it gives us this serve command
which basically calls this package view
cli service that's from vue.js
gives it the serve command and it will
run a development server for us
so there's no more of the old
complicated server setup that we had in
the last
version of this in the last application
the build command is really for when we
want to host our project live
this will generate production ready
files for you like your html css and
javascript so you can deploy them and
have a live website somewhere
we're just going to be talking about
this command
in this video
and to give you an idea of what it does
let's go ahead and run it
i can use npm to run the command so npm
run
server
and now my app is running at port 8080.
if i highlight something in the terminal
it automatically copies
i'm going to come to my browser
open a new tab
and i can see it gives me an app already
set up out of the box
and because we chose to install a router
as well
it installed the default
view router which is also called view
router
and you can see i can go to different
page routes
now this isn't the same as our last
application because there is no page
refresh in between page routes these are
not html links this is just a javascript
router rendering hiding or showing
different pages of this application
you'll also notice
from the home page it's just port 8080.
when we go to the about page it adds
slash about
if we look in the public folder here
you can see here's our html page
and we have a div of id app and this is
where our app
will be injected
but also when our application is built
under the hood this vue cli service
command
is running webpack and bundling all of
our files together
and also handling running babble to
transpile our files and so all of the
javascript and everything will be
injected as script tags as well here
but we generally don't have to worry
about this
index.html file in view project
because again most of what we will be
doing is in the source folder right here
so we have a main.js file that is always
created for us
so this is basically the same thing that
we did in the previous application
if you do see
view 2 code this file will look a little
bit different
but you'll still be able to see the
different parts
just the organization and syntax is a
little bit different
just like before we have to pass in a
root component
we chain on
any packages that we want to use in this
case the router
and then we mount that to the dom so
inside of
the div with id of app
and you could also rewrite this as
const app
and then app.use router
and then app.mount
that's a bit easier to parse through as
you add more packages
now when we're looking at this initial
page where does all of this come from
let's take a look
so we have our main component app
but you'll notice in app there's no real
content here
all it is is a div
this is basically the top navigation
now where did this router link come from
this is a custom component actually
and if you look in our main js when we
use app
dot use router we are actually given
some components like router link
as well as router view
now router link
is actually a substitution
for using the anchor tag
to link to another page
except router link is made by vue router
specifically for
single page application routing
where our javascript handles the routing
instead of linking to a separate html
page
of course we only have
one html page
and
all of our static content is injected
into that one page and the router
handles intercepting the route making it
appear as though you've navigated to
another page
while really it's just showing and
hiding different elements on the dom
so we have these two router links and
then what does router view do so router
view
is actually our page content
and our router will handle replacing
this router view tag
with whatever component we tell it to in
our routes file that we are about to
look at
so router view is just a temporary
placeholder
for whatever we put on the page
and you'll see as we navigate to
different pages
those home and about links at the top of
this file those will stay no matter what
page we navigate to but all of the
content below it will change because
those are the components getting
injected
into this router view area here
if we look into
our router index.js file here
we can see that we are using the view
router api
to create a router
and when we create a router here we're
passing in two things
so the routes
which is an array of all our routes that
we have in the application
and then history mode
it set this up for us because we chose
to use history mode
and vue is handling all of that under
the hood
but let's talk about the routes here
so we have the default home route
which is this page
and then we also have the about page
which is found at this route
now you don't have to worry about code
splitting and lazy loading and all of
that other stuff those are more advanced
routing concepts
so i'm going to get rid of that line
and then just import the about component
just like the home component now you
basically define routes here
and instead of importing the components
that you want to show on a page into
your app.view
you just
use a router view
tag here
and then you import any of your view
components like home and about
into this file
you define the path where that component
can be found at
the name of that component now the name
is mostly used for
routing and then you tell it which
component will be found
at that path
so at the home path
we're going to find the home component
now where is the home component we can
see that it is in views
slash home
so let's go in here
and we can see
that
this is the component
it has an image which is the view logo
on top
and then it also imports another
component into itself
now this component is not in the views
folder it's in the components directory
now why is it in the components
directory
instead of just one folder for all view
files
basically in front-end applications
files are usually split up between views
or pages so basically anything in this
views folder will be connected to the
router so they will have their own
routes they'll be their own pages
anything in the components folder
are things that are imported
into other components they're meant to
be
parts of pages or reusable components
that you use throughout your application
basically anything in the views folder
is connected to the router
and if it's not connected to the router
and just imported into another component
then put it in the components folder
and you'll see at the home route
there's a view image at the top
and then there are all of these
links here
and that's exactly what we see in the
home route
now if we go to the about page
it's not importing any other components
or doing anything fancy
there's only this h1 so a header with
that text
which is what we see when we go to the
about page
assets of course are a place for usually
css images anything like that to live
sometimes you will see other folders
created here in view projects but these
are the basic ones the only one that we
are going to add later is the store
folder and we'll talk about that in a
few videos
in the next video we are going to start
transferring
our content over from our old static
application into our view application
let's start moving things over one by
one starting with the home page
i'm going to go over to my original code
here
into source
and then go into my
app.html here
the first thing that i need to grab is
this header now i do have some
javascript functionality in here and
i'll handle hooking that up in a minute
but let me just copy paste for right now
and move this
over to a new file
now i'm going to need it on this home
page here
but since this header is actually my
app-wide navigation
i am actually going to want to
replace the navigation here
so that i can use this and see this on
any page
and for right now i'm going to get rid
of these
now there's a bit of cleanup that i need
to do here
because these anchor tags
need to be changed
to the view router router link tags
and now i need an actual route
so instead of pointing to an html file i
am going to give it a route that will be
in
my router here linked to a component
so i have this
products.html here
what i'm going to do
is change that to slash products
of course this can't be an href this
will be 2
since that's expected by the router link
i also need to change this from href to
2.
and i can just call this route past
orders get rid of the dot html
and here as well
change this to 2
and this should just be a forward slash
i'm not going to worry
about
this yet
this last router link at the bottom i'm
going to just comment that out for right
now
and basically i need to create these
three components that are linked to the
routes
now i already have the home route here
that is linked to the home component
i'm actually going to get rid of about
and i'm going to change this to
products
i'm going to have to create a new
component
and now let me delete about from here
and let me create a new file
i'll call this
products
dot view
now this is a little bit different
instead of calling this
just a regular javascript file with
extension js
view has a custom file extension which
is dot view
all of these dot view files are parsed
by the view and webpack setup that the
view cli sets up for us
so using these dot view files we can put
our html template our javascript and
even our css all in the same file
that gets parsed and all put together
and bundled by the tools that view cli
sets up for us
now i have a new file
i'm just going to create a template in
here
and i have four spaces i'm gonna switch
to using two spaces
for tab spacing
and i'm just gonna put h1
products for right now
all right
before we get too far let's see how this
looks
and we do have a products page and a
home page now
but of course this is completely
unstyled
let's pause here and start to bring over
some of the styles in the next video
let's start to move our styles over
now our styles are going to live inside
of this assets
folder and i can go ahead and create a
folder inside of there called styles
now how do i use styles in my project
if you come to this app component here
you'll notice that there is a style tag
at the bottom
of the component and these are what is
providing custom styles for the
application
if i look in my browser this is what is
styling and centering the elements
if i get rid of these styles
this is what it looks like without any
of those custom styles
in any view component you can add styles
directly inside of that component
so if i wanted to do something
i could change all h1 tags
to the color of
blue
and you'll notice this is just plain css
here that you can write inside of these
view files
now if i go here you can see
that this is an h1 tag
and it is changed to being blue
also on the products tag that is blue as
well because that is another h1
now
if i look at this though
those h1 elements are nowhere to be
found
in this component
those are actually in other components
but by default the style tag globally
affects anything in the application so
if i put a style tag here even though
it's in the app.view file
anywhere in my application that has an
h1 tag can be affected by this
now this is generally not good practice
because if you want to globally change a
style you should put that in a separate
style sheet so in some other dot css
file
here if i'm putting styles inside of my
app.view file
generally
what i intend to do
is
only let it affect
the app.view file
so it won't change styles in any other
component right it'll only affect
whatever is in my template in this file
and that's why i use the scope keyword
here now now that i've added the scope
keyword
so you can see that the text changed
back to black
because now
that i've scoped this it is only
affecting styles within this
view component not in other components
throughout the application
now if i wanted to
add an external style sheet
let me just go ahead and create a
temporary one here
i'll call this main.css
and let me paste in my last style and
i'll change the color
this will not affect my application yet
because i have to import the css file
now instead of importing this into one
of my html files what view does is allow
me to import it directly
into my javascript
so generally that would be this main.js
file what i can do is import
from assets
styles
and then
that main.css
and the vue cli
up webpack for me in such a way that i
can import styles directly into my
javascript
and it is all handled by the tooling
so now if i go back to my browser
it's a little bit darker but you can
tell that this is purple now
because i am importing it globally
into my project
from this main.css file
those are the basics of how you import
styles into an application
now if i come back to my original static
application
with our html files that we were using
if i come to styles here you can see
that these aren't just css files they
are sas files
for the most part
so how do i get these into my project if
they aren't standard css files
so vue also has built-in ways of
handling this
let me copy
these styles
and i'm going to delete this styles
folder here
and
i'm going to paste
so i pasted in this
styles folder from my other project
and now if i look in this folder
there is one file
called style.scss
which is a sas file
and this imports all of the rest
of the files here all of my other sas
files
now it is this file that i really want
to import into my project
to get all of my styles
i'm going to comment this out and now
i'll import that sas file directly
from assets
styles
slash style dot
scss
i'll save that
and now you can see that it is giving me
an error saying can't resolve sas loader
so it's trying to
load those sas files
but since they aren't regular css we
have to add another module to be able to
import those files
and that is like it says sass loader
if we look in the view cli documentation
and go to working with css under
development
we can see that it has this section on
preprocessors
now as it mentions we can select our
preprocessor when we're creating the
project
meaning when we ran that first view
create project name that command would
take us through setting up sas
automatically
now since we did not
choose sas back then when we were
setting it up
there are ways of adding these packages
which you can do through this command
npm install and then installing the sas
loader
and also the sas package
now if i scroll down a little bit
it is giving me this note about webpack
which is what i'm using in view cli for
i have to make sure i have a compatible
version of these loaders so i am going
to go ahead and grab
this npm install command where i can
install sas loader add a specific
version and also sas
and it installed those packages for me
now i should be able to run my server
once again
at npm run serve
now it is complaining that i don't have
one specific css module because i
haven't installed it in my node modules
but that is actually a good sign because
that means that it is reading through
the rest of my file here it's reading
through this
getting to this line and saying hey i
can't find that file
so i'm just going to comment that out
for right now
and now we have one more error here
and that is
it's looking for images that it can't
find right now
let's go ahead and resolve those
and they're coming from
this file
so
if i go to splash dot
sas
now you'll notice the syntax is a little
bit different here
you can basically think of it as just an
indented syntax without curly braces
either way you can see that the
attributes are the same here so i have
background image it's looking for this
image
and again there's a background image
which is looking for this green image
so i'm going to
create an images folder here
in img folder and put those two images
inside of the img folder
and then update this path
so back in my old application
they were in my public directory i have
green
and splash
i'm gonna copy those
and
paste them here
and i should be able to
reference the relative path here
close this file
and you can see i have the styles for my
main application in here now
let me do one more thing and get rid of
this boilerplate here
so i can be ready to put my own content
there
so let me
get out of here
and go to
source slash views and home
i'll get rid of this image
also get rid of that component i'm just
going to put home here for now
and get rid of the component everywhere
now if i go back to this page you can
see that it is ready to add my own
custom content
and i can see the products page and
navigates as well one more thing i'll go
ahead and do
is add a past orders page to the router
at this route
and all i'll have to do
is basically
copy
the products route
this will be past orders
i can call it past
orders
past orders
now i need to create this component
it's connected to my router so i'm going
to create it in the views folder
call it past
orders
dot view
and
i have a shortcut snippet here
i'll show you how to use this in a
second but if i click enter
it just created the template tag for me
and i'm going to put in each one in here
that says
past
orders
and now i have this page working so all
three pages are there
in the next video i'll be putting
content on these pages and then hooking
them up to javascript to be functional
now let's work on putting actual content
on this home page
i'm in the original application now let
me go to source
inside of
views here
i have my pages actually the main page
is still in app.html
so i'm going to go ahead and grab these
two container elements here the div and
the main container
copy those
go over to
my new code
my vcli project
and here i can come to my home page
and
just paste that in here
all right
now take this
adjust the indentation get rid of that
old word
and now i have my splash container
and also my main container
and nothing is showing up on the page
so if i look in the dev tools it says
cannot read property slice of undefined
and i can search for
where that is being used
and inventory.slice so
of course it is broken right now because
i don't have
any inventory
so let me grab that from my original
code base
if i go here i can see in food.json
this file is really where i have my
inventory items
so i'm going to copy this file
copy
go over here
and inside of source i'm just going to
paste that file
and now i need to import this into
my vue.js
so if i want this right now in my home
component
i need to import it at the bottom here
so let me import my data
so import
food from
go up a directory food
dot json
let's set it equal to
a data variable
so data and then i can return
and then
i can set inventory equal to food
okay let's try this out
and now we see the banner displays just
fine
and we can see our recommended product
section at the bottom which is already
displaying real data
because we already set this up
and this is basically the same logic as
with the other app
but we've only rewritten this in a
component structure
now let's pull in the other pages really
quick
so we have past orders and also products
let's go to products
and if i go to the products page
i can just grab this main section here
go back over to my code
and then paste that in
now this page should work as it is
because if i look at all of the code
here we never made that dynamic
so that's something that we will have to
change later but this is all hard coded
let me grab the past orders page real
quick and then we can take a look at it
in the browser
so if i go to past orders
let me fold
this main section
i'm gonna copy this
and go over here to my code
paste that
and now let's take a look at these pages
okay so our past orders page has an
error
and it's complaining that this i tag
which was used for icons generally that
it doesn't have a closing tag
meaning it's not explicitly self-closing
and i'm not explicitly closing it either
like this tt dag here
has a closing td tag there
so i will have to fix that that's just
how view templates work
so let me search for i
and seems like it's only in two places
which is good
all i have to do to fix that
is either i could do
a closing tag
things like img and i and
certain tags don't really have closing
tags so all i have to do is make them
self closing
since you're never going to nest
anything inside of this tag in general
so i'm just adding the forward slash at
the end
and i will do that with this eye as well
and that fixed my error and now here's
the products page
and the past orders page as well this is
kind of a table view
of previous orders
now what about the sidebar let's add
that logic back in in the next video
in our original application we had this
sidebar on the right to display our cart
in this video we're going to move that
over to our new vue cli application
so i'm in the original code base
if i go to
any of my files i can see there is a
sidebar component
which is a custom view component that i
define in my app.js file
this sidebar component that i register
and i can basically use it globally
throughout my application
now of course this is just regular view
code so i could absolutely do the same
thing in my new application
but there are other ways that i can now
create reusable components
so i'm actually going to put it in my
components folder instead
i'm going to copy all of that
let me go to components i have this old
hello world component
i'm going to delete it because i don't
need it anymore
and then i'm going to create a new file
here
and call this
sidebar dot view
in here of course i need the template
and i'm going to paste
all of that code
and this is basically all of the cart
logic now there are a few things i will
need to add
pass in a dynamic toggle here when the
button is clicked
so let me go ahead and set that up
now the first thing i need to do is
import this sidebar component into my
application and it's going to be
globally available across all my pages
so i'm going to import it into
my app.view file
and i'll do it below
actually i'll do it at the bottom here
i'm going to put
sidebar
it has to be of course self-closing here
and also the convention is to capitalize
custom components
so you can easily see them and see
they're even highlighted differently
than anything that is lowercase that
i've pulled in from a library or that is
just standard html
i'm going to get rid of my style tag
here and add a script tag
and now i can import that component so
i'm going to import sidebar
from
dot slash components
slash
sidebar dot view
now another way of writing this and what
you'll a lot of times see in view
applications
instead here you'll see an at sign
now this is a shortcut kind of a
reference to the source folder so that
way anywhere in my application no matter
how many files deep my components are i
don't have to do anything like
dot dot slash dot dot slash dot dot etc
i can always reference the source folder
with an at symbol
so it will be source slash components
slash sidebar dot view
now any component that i import into
another component
i need to register it and tell my view
application i'm going to be using
this component
and i can do that by setting a component
object
on this default
options object in view
and i can set the sidebar component here
registering it here or including it in
the list of components here just means
that i can use it up here
in my template
so how this works basically this whole
object here it's called the options
object
and any kind of javascript functions or
data will get set on this object
i just want to point out that this is
the exact same
as the options object you used in custom
components like this one except the
template
in our dot view file is just included at
the top up here inside of this template
and if we look at
this main
app component here
everything inside this object all of
this data computed methods
all of this stuff is the options object
but here we have it to be used globally
and when we create a view cli
application
we basically get one template
and one options object per component
that we use to define everything on now
the thing about this is that each
component only knows about the
javascript inside the options object of
that component
so if i create a function here
i can only use it up here and in no
other component
unless i explicitly pass it into that
component to be used
just the same way that we passed data
and functions around
two different components when we were
building the static application
and here we're going to need to do that
again because sidebar requires certain
things to be passed in
now if we look
here we can see that first there is a v
if boolean
there's a function to toggle the sidebar
when it's clicked or when the button is
clicked to open or close it there's also
a cart
object for what is currently inside the
cart
there are all of our inventory items and
then there is a remove item function
so i'm going to copy all of these things
and paste them over here
and now i need to define these
properties
first thing is vf
i need to create
a show sidebar
data property here
and i'm going to set this just default
as true for right now so i can see the
sidebar
now i need a toggle sidebar function
now where does this come from
it has to come from my app component up
here because i'm passing it in
basically from app to the sidebar
component
so here's my toggle sidebar function
and i'm just going to grab all of these
functions right now
and i'll create that methods object
and i pasted in all of my methods here
now here's another tricky part because
i want to reference inventory here but
unfortunately
i only have it in my home component
which i just kind of quickly put there
to fix my issue of basically inventory
being undefined so i'm going to have to
restructure my application so i'm not
importing inventory separately into each
component
so let me actually take this import and
i'm going to just import inventory
into
my app.view component
so i'm importing it here
and then my logic here so inventory is
food
and i'm going to add that to
data as well
so inventory is food now i need to get
it
to my home component
but it's not really a registered
component on this page like sidebar
i can easily pass elements into sidebar
as props because it's a registered
component right here but home is a
little bit different because the router
is dynamically putting the home
component there
so how do i pass props through the
router then to whatever component the
router loads
what we're going to do is pass in
inventory into
basically any router view component so
i'm going to pass in the inventory
variable
and of course i need to v bind this
to
make it actually look for a variable and
not consider it to just be a string here
so now i'm passing in inventory
and i need to accept that
in the child component
so instead of data here
i'm actually going to have to use props
just as i did before
and have a props object
or i'll just do it as an array actually
and i have to call it inventory
there are a few more broken elements
that i will have to fix here
that the sidebar is expecting
i have my inventory and remove item
and i really just need my cart at this
point
now if i look in the original version
i can see the cart is just an empty
object
and then things can be dynamically added
to the cart
but we're going to worry about
dynamically adding things in a minute
but first i'll just set it to an empty
object
so let me go to data here
and set cart
to an empty object
really quick let's go ahead and grab
this computed property as well because
we will need it
so i'll come down here and put computed
and let's check this out in the browser
so it's complaining right now that it
can't find this json file
and that's because we are importing it
from the wrong place
and yay the app is running
products past orders
everything seems to be working okay
however we don't have the sidebar yet so
let me go ahead and uncomment this code
here
so we have toggle sidebar and also
showing the quantity and the button here
so here
i should be able to see the button that
we had before in our previous
application
all right when i come here and refresh
nothing shows up
so we have some kind of an issue it says
uncaught type error
can't find path of undefined so the path
this is referring to the router
so i think it's giving us an error in
the router link
because we are not properly using the
router link
so let me just change this to a div we
basically aren't telling it to route
anywhere we are just using it as a
clickable element
so we might as well be using something
else
and now it is working
except i can't click on the cart button
that's not working yet but everything
else is working let me scroll up to see
my original error here
so
it says cannot convert undefined or null
to an object
and this loop is basically inside
of my sidebar component so it's
complaining about this line here line
25.
i'm trying to loop through a cart object
get the quantity and key as well as the
index
and basically it's saying that cart must
be undefined value
so let me take a look
in my
app here
it's
not opening so let me actually take a
look at the original code
and inside of my app.js
i have all of this code moved over
except this mounted here but i don't
need that anymore because
i can now directly import the json file
i don't need to fetch it
so here's my sidebar component
and actually i didn't copy over
any of the methods here and i'm also
forgetting to add in the props
so let me go ahead and do that just copy
this
go back here to sidebar
and i do need a script tag at the bottom
here
so i'm going to add
a script tag
paste in the props
and then i also want the methods from
here so i'm going to grab those as well
now calculate total and get price are
defined and then i also have all of the
props here so let's see if this works
yay
and the toggle is perfectly working
of course it's starting off as open if i
refresh it just automatically opens
so let me change that
in app.view
i'll come here and say show sidebar is
false
all right
let me see if we can
use this
so it's not dynamically adding items to
the cart yet
so we will fix that in the next video
in this video we are going to hook up
the add to cart functionality so that
when we add to cart here it will show up
in the sidebar
if i look in the terminal right now
you can see that this add to cart it's
saying it's not a function
so i'm getting an error when i click
this add to cart button
now i can see why i'm getting that
because that is in my home page
component
and if i go down here i can see this add
to cart function that i'm calling when i
click that button
is not defined anywhere in this
component
where is that function defined
it is in the app.view file
so if i go to
my methods i can see i have an add to
cart method right here
i basically need to pass this function
into my home page for my home page to be
able to use so i'm going to also pass
that through the router as i did before
and then in my home page i can also
receive that as a prop
add that onto the props list add to cart
so i should have access to the function
that i passed into this home component
now
through the router view
and let me refresh and see if this works
add to cart
and you can see that the function is
working because the quantity changed
down to zero
the cart says two items and if i open it
it does indeed list two items here
now why are there forward slashes here
we can actually see
in the home page
that in
regular javascript
this is actually in the sidebar
component
that in order to put a dollar sign
before the variable
we need to escape it but we don't have
to do that
in a vjs application
because it's no longer in a regular
javascript file it's in our vue.js
template
so i can get rid of
all of these escaping
characters
and now that looks much better now if i
want to
delete this it deletes no longer have
any items in the cart
i can add a couple items and i get items
in the cart
if i go to another page the cart should
still work
because that is a shared component that
i can see
across any page
in simple applications
this type of data sharing works pretty
well
we can keep all of our variables in a
parent component so in this case in our
app.view component
we pass functions and variables down to
children
and then children can call functions
like add to cart
that will then update the state of the
parent component
now in more complicated applications
we would need something a little bit
more robust for
state management
and being able to share all of this data
throughout our application
and we will talk about that in a future
series
where we cover vue x
which is
vue.js's default state management
library
but for right now we are going to leave
the application as it is and work on it
in future series and lessons
so we have the home page
the cart sidebar
now we really need to hook up some of
the information on this page so the
products page
and it's really exactly the same as the
products section
here on the home page we have all of the
same kind of cards and information
so since we have the same thing pretty
much
in multiple places of the application it
makes sense to pull out all of this ui
that makes up these cards into its own
component and then we can share it
across the application and on any page
that we want
so let's go ahead and create a card
component
now in components here i'm going to
create a new file
and i'm going to call this product card
dot view
i'll start with a template
and now i'm going to go to
my home page
and i can see there's a for loop here
that is looping through and displaying
all of the cards
so i'm going to grab this whole card
here
and paste it in
my
product card file
now this is just an individual card
so i don't need a for loop in here
let me get rid of this logic
and this will just be one card now i
will need the product information for
this card to display correctly
so i'm going to have to accept that as a
prop in my component
so let me create a script tag
i'll create props here
just an array of props
and i'm going to say
product
so i accept the product props
into my component and now i can use it
in my template
now
i can remove all of this logic
from here
and the only thing i need is actually to
import that component
so i need to import
product card from i'm going to use my
source folder shortcut
slash components
and slash
product card dot view
and now i need to register this as a
component so i can use it
and now in my code up here
i'm going to use
product card
i'll clean up the lines a little bit
here
and i need to make this
closing because all tags and view
templates need to either be self closing
or having a closing tag
now i'm no longer using
this index here
i'm going to see
in my product
if i'm using the index anywhere
and i am indeed passing in the index so
i will need to accept
the index
as a prop as well
let me change this to
index so it's a little bit more clear
and
i will get index here
and i'm going to
pass that in here
of course index is a variable not a
string so i'll have to v bind that
and that should work here let's see if
this works
and we are getting an error here
now that is because
product is now a prop
and of course we cannot mutate props
from the parent component
so we can actually fix this by not
mapping to
the product prop at all
we're actually going to create
a local variable inside of this product
component
so each component
each time we use the product card
component
it will have its own local variable
and we can do that by adding a data prop
here and
in the method we need return
it returns an object and now we can
simply map quantity
because each card
only has one input box
so we'll just map it internally in the
card
and we can check that this works
i'm not sure why it only has two cards
right now
but let's try this
so i press the number two
and i can look in my vjs
dev tools
and i'm getting an error here
and it says i can't read property name
of undefined
so
product.name
yes i believe i have forgotten to
pass in the correct props here
so let me add those
i need to pass in
product
equals product
and then while i'm here let me also add
the
add to cart function
equals
add to cart
there we go
and now let's check if the page loads
and the page is loading
all right so now we have all of the
cards loading
and let me just look
in my view dev tools i can see
all of my product card components so let
me just take a look
if i change this to 2
and i can see the quantity is 2.
if i change it to 22 it's now 22.
all right so that is mapping correctly
now i need to get this quantity the
value
up through the home component to the app
component where i am actually performing
the function of adding it to the cart
so what i'm going to do
for right now i'm just going to pass in
a third parameter
and i will pass in quantity
and now let's take a look at
our function our add to cart function
in the app component
so we are adding items onto the cart
if they're not already there
and then we are basically
incrementing the number here
so now that we have that third parameter
being passed in which is
the quantity
all we have to do
is change this line
to be plus equals quantity
which is now getting passed in
and then of course we don't need this
line because we are no longer mapping
to a nested quantity
rather we have
the quantity variable right here this
also means that we don't need to pass up
the index anymore
so we can remove that from this function
we only need the name and the quantity
basically so that we can add it to the
cart
let's check and see if this works
if i come here
the number still maps to the component
now if i click add to cart
it is not in my cart let's see if we got
an error
add to cart is not a function
let me look inside of my home dot view
i have add to cart that i am getting
from the parent component so from the
app component i'm passing that in to the
product card and i should have it
oh right i didn't accept it as a prop
inside of the product card
so now let's see if this works let me
refresh
and go into my view dev tools
and now i can see it's properly working
here
if i want to add
10 artichokes and i have two radishes
and i have 12 items in the cart
now my rounding functionality isn't
properly working
as you can see
but it is
properly adding and displaying the
quantity and the total in the cart
but i don't just want this functionality
on the home page i also want it on the
products page
so let me import
those components into the products page
now
so if i come to my products.view file
i actually have access to inventory
already in here because if you remember
in my app.view
i am passing inventory and the add to
cart function into anything displayed by
the router view which is basically any
of our pages here home past orders or
products
they're all connected to our router
so let's accept those props in the
products page to start with
first let me fold up all of these cards
get them out of the way
so let me do a script tag
props
and
i'm going to accept
inventory
and
add to cart
one more thing i need to do is import
this product card
so i'm gonna go to the home component
and just copy this import
and paste it
into product or into the products page
and now i need to define this
as a component here
product card
and this should be components not
component
and i also have one more error here
which this should be a capital p
and now if i see if i highlight this all
of these
highlight let me take a look at what
this error is here
the product card component has been
registered but not use
so let's fix that
so i basically have all of these cards
here
for the different items that show up on
the page i'm actually going to just
delete
all of these right now
and instead i'm going to add the product
card
so if i go to home
i can
take a look at my product card
that i'm actually using inside the
template
and i'm just going to copy that and
paste it here
but instead of slicing at three here let
me just do the first six elements
instead
now because we already have inventory
being passed in
as well as the add to cart function of
course inside the loop
we're taking care of the product
variable there's really no other state
that we have locally
on the products component
so this should pretty much work out of
the box for us
let's check here
and we can see that it does indeed loop
through and display all of the cards on
the products page
now
let me add a couple of these items to
the cart here
and you can see the cart just updated
with five
if i add a few artichokes let's add some
cherries
and
some cabbage carrots
everything right we have 17 items in the
cart now
and we can see that it added all of
these items
now if i go to the home page i can still
see
17 items in the cart
because we moved to a single page
application
all of our routing is handled by the
vue.js javascript and we are actually
sharing state between components
so all of the state for our cart lives
in the app component
which is the parent component
of all the other pages the home page the
product page
and that's why all of the items in the
cart all of the data that we save here
in our application it stays no matter
what page we navigate to
and even though
this is displayed or this card is on
multiple pages
you can see how vue made it very easy
for us to reuse the same code and the
same template to loop through and
display wherever we wanted on the
application
and that's basically how reusable
components work in vue.js
i hope you enjoyed this course and you
learned a lot about vjs learning it on
three different levels through this
course
we started off working in a basic
index.html file
and then we went on
to a static site upgrading it a little
bit with some view.js
and then we moved on to using the vue
cli
and creating a fully dynamic single page
application that we have here
definitely reach out to me if you have
any feedback comments or questions about
this course
you can find me on twitter and pretty
much everywhere online as going faraday
or at faraday academy
have a great day and i hope to see you
in the next course